thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation a big massive dump
elephants and bathrooms
[Music]
elephants
[Music]
[Music]
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms I'm
worried about my espresso machine I'm
not that could be your headlight
it's not a joke it's just I'm worried
about my Lane
and
um
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
the lawyers are lawyers the lawyers are
lawyers get rid of the machine I'm
trying for getting rid of the machine
[Music]
and they put up better protection virus
protection but here's what my attorney
said he said um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
it's really incredible The Branding
around that she said no if you're not
giving my phone I said arrest me I've
done nothing mommy said no we're not
gonna arrest you I swear you can do
anything you have yet and you can do it
you can deal again
um get rid of the machine I've tried
from getting rid of the machine I'm
worried about my pillow no no dude
that's the worst thing for you because
your cervical nerves in your neck I will
send you some pillows
getting rid of the machine
thank you
[Music]
I love mangoes too
my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
mangoes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
be affected
don't want me to me
and highway robbery is what you doing
[Music]
mangoes if anyone Donald Trump killed
Donald Trump I love Donald Trump but no
more dropped by the drop boxes are just
so bad no more drop boxes Dickinson
hologic and cephe cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
back by building something called truth
truth Central he voted against Kate's
law and he voted for Obama
you know we've endorsed Dr Oz we've
endorsed
JP right JD Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive come on what's that
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the broad star and the
combat infantry bin badge for his
service we have to keep our country gay
people but it's not I mean for some
reason it's just not great anymore if
you care about law and auto look Law and
Order in normal times roughly 40 percent
of fresh vegetables at about 40 percent
China nambia's health system is
increasingly self-sufficient this is not
about virtue cycling and signing and the
great General and President
Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really
come back a long way over the last 10
years hasn't he
we appreciate it very much Tim Apple
when they gaze upon Yosemite cosemites
towering Sequoias they deliver they
swept and swept in you know that
sweeping it was Swift and it was
sleeping like nobody's ever seen
anything happen units of plasma for
plasma donate plasma into failing New
York Times by
Anonymous it's really an anonymous
gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading woman's business the teacher
should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children while not
correct up yourself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administrating against this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you've heard them and you know them well
they sacrifice every day for the
furniture future our army man the
airport it ran the ramparts it took over
the airports it did everything it had to
do this is the very definition of
totalitarianism Michigan gave us botang
gave us Motown gave us the Mustang
shifting production to Thailand and to
Vietnam Thailand and Vietnam the biggest
lie ever foistered upon the American
people our embassies in Kenya and
Tanzania your Campaign Of Terror murder
Mayhem will not be tolerated any longer
it will not
be allowed to go forward and let me
Begin by wishing you a
free health care
inherit the Legacy oh you know what
right
all right welcome everybody I was uh too
entertained myself to get away from that
it is election night in America I am so
glad to have you here this is an
inflection point for the United States
of America the world is watching and the
world is horrified a guy who cannot
speak might be the next senator from
Georgia
a guy who was at the Trump riots might
be the next governor of Pennsylvania
a quack doctor not even from
Pennsylvania might be the next senator
from Pennsylvania
and it only gets worse from there I am
so glad to have you with us the first
results are starting to come in no
controversial results so far but we are
going to catch everybody up we are
monitoring all the feeds we evolved the
election dashboards and results we are
not going to get ahead of ourselves like
with what we see on the screen right now
we're not going to get ahead of
ourselves with what we see on the screen
I'm not going to do it to you because we
don't want later to have to cry okay
everybody understand so we're not gonna
get everybody just relax
it is just after 7 30 p.m in the East
and 4 30 p.m in the west we have had
some we might call them sporadic pole
closures so far well I'll cry later but
for other reasons okay please
and in 24 minutes at the top of the hour
at the stroke of 8 P.M uh there's
something a little weird here in my in
my uh let me see if I can fix that there
we go at the stroke of 8 PM in the East
and 5 p.m in the west we are going to
get a number of additional poll closures
but let's do an initial run through
everything let me tell you what we have
going here you're going to be able to
keep up with everything on this one
stream first of all we are monitoring
CNN secondly we are monitoring Fox News
as they call it uh we are also
monitoring NBC
we are monitoring the CNN panel which is
really not bad this is the uh
gubernatorial element as you can see
early results from Florida have Ron
DeSantis well ahead not a surprise we
are expecting DeSantis to win early
results from Georgia have Stacy Abrams
ahead
folks trust me on this
it is extraordinarily early
Abrams is not favored to win it's 16 of
the vote let's vote let's hope let's do
it all but let's not get
ahead of ourselves there uh okay so
those are interesting we have the CNN
Senate numbers and when you look at
those numbers you see that the incumbent
Maggie Hassan is fortunately ahead in
New Hampshire if train wreck Don balduck
were to win
uh uh I don't know I it wouldn't be good
it really wouldn't be good not a
surprise young very much ahead in
Indiana uh in the senate in Kentucky
Rand Paul is ahead some networks have
already called it for Rand Paul so
that's essentially it very uh Tim Scott
not Tim Apple
Tim Scott has uh it's been called in the
senate for South Carolina he's an
incumbent not a surprise in North
Carolina very very very important race
and again folks I don't I
I don't want to get ourselves we we're
getting city data early we are getting
city data early obviously it would be an
incredible result for Beasley to defeat
Bud okay it's 60 40 right now 33 of the
vote in this is heavily places like
Asheville okay Asheville is two-thirds
in the county containing Charlotte is 50
percent in
uh Relic is 54 in okay Durham all these
places are heavily Democratic and they
are heavily in so I'm just telling you
guys let's not get ahead of ourselves
here long long time to go okay but North
Carolina very interesting
Senate in Georgia
you understand right does everybody
understand
you know when a pitcher is pitching a
perfect game
and it's the eighth inning you don't go
wow only one more inning to go until the
perfect game
people understand what I'm saying right
okay everybody sees what's on the screen
that's it okay walk away turn around and
walk away and then sadly in Florida
listen Marco Rubio was leading by quite
a bit
and with 61 percent of the vote in Rubio
is up nine over congresswoman Val
demings so we do what we can we do what
we can with the house it's hard to even
look at specific races
um nothing from the fourth district oh
wait hold on 14th is green
uh Marjorie Taylor green just running
away with it only three percent of the
vote in but Marjorie Taylor green
running away with it I don't even know
that there are specific house races that
we necessarily want to look at at this
point in time okay so these are the CNN
panels we also have decision desk and
we've got Senate house and Governor
actually I should put Governor first so
we've got Governor Senate and House on
decision desk we have the New York Times
ones as well we're monitoring that so we
have all of it all of it all of it all
of it and we will be monitoring all of
these different networks
extraordinarily important day and that's
why I'm so happy to have all of you here
with us where to even start let's start
with some super chats David sir I was on
my way to my local ballot Dropbox when I
was accosted by a fax machine an
answering machine and a vending machine
they stole my ballot and my wife who's
now up in the air yeah that's a lot
that's a lot I can't even deal with that
right now David I voted against the
ballot measure in Utah didn't really
understand too well what it was
addressing do you know about it I I'm
not up to speed on the ballot measures
in Utah I will admit the blah has just
gifted five subscriptions via YouTube I
very much appreciate that by the way
folks I'm not even gonna we have too
much going on to focus on this we have a
goal of getting to 1500 website members
and twitch subscribers today we're at
almost 1100 this this is day five
I think I think we potentially are going
to be able to get there okay very
important I voted in Pennsylvania
overall pretty good there were some
mastriano supporters canvassing outside
they didn't seem violent but I'm not
sure if that's legal depends how close
they are
I voted for Matt castelli in New York 21
stefanik is so far right she didn't even
agree to a debate with castelli
David I need so badly to know your
thoughts about DeSantis blocking the
federal election monitors Tristan I have
it bookmarked for tomorrow to talk about
I don't yet know the details
Swami live says I was going to vote but
the only names on my ballot were Swami
Vive kanmundund kanundun and
suchintendalker I don't care for either
[Music]
yeah that's a tough situation that's for
damn sure folks 18 minutes until the
next poll closures I can't
wait
and I'm not going to wait to thank
Espress who just gifted a hundred
subscriptions be it via twitch also
welcome to Trish the dish camera at
ageist oceanova and Breezy putting us at
1182. super chats are coming in almost
faster than I can keep up with them
psycho Farm crossing fingers on
recreational cannabis in South Dakota
Tyler when I voted in Maine there were
people Gathering signatures for a voter
ID referendum wondering if others
experienced this
Michael says thanks for everything you
and your team do you guys are the voice
of reason logic and Sanity thank you
Michael
2020 he had a red Mirage 2022 looks like
maybe a blue Mirage
we are simply watching the results
watching the results
is the Senate the most important race
explain which is the most important and
how it will affect us as a country no so
there is no one most important let me
break it down this way and people in the
chat if I'm missing if if I'm ignoring
kind of like the importance of these
three different elements how Senate and
gubernatorial
the Senate is extremely important
because without control of the Senate
Democrats are dead in the water about
even debating things that Joe Biden and
Democrats want to do disaster okay
federal judges depend on the Senate
Supreme Court nominations depend on the
Senate that's the important of the
Senate House of Representatives House of
Representatives has investigative Powers
they almost certainly are going to start
bogus investigations into Joe Biden
Hunter Biden they may well
impeach Joe Biden they will obstruct
anything Biden and the Senate want to do
and the House of Representatives
combined with the Senate can wreak
absolute havoc in the 2024 presidential
election
gubernatorial is important for two
reasons number one much of what is done
in the United States because of
Federalism is done at the state level
and so Governors and secretaries of
State very important in addition we know
we know
they are going to try to steal 2024 if
they don't win
and the way you do that is with
Governors and secretaries of state so
all of these are extraordinarily
important all of these are
extraordinarily important for different
reasons okay I hope that I have made
myself very clear
thank you to I Keebler as well as Waylon
Smith a for the twitch Prime
subscriptions also tiny sir Jen and fun
fun each just gifted five subscriptions
putting us at 11.94 folks do not adjust
your screens these are real numbers
these are real numbers I do have to
think and we're not going to do a ton of
time on this we're going to have to run
it in a different way because it's too
explosive tonight what's happening on
the website there are
14 people who just got memberships on my
website that puts us at 1208 today is
the last day for the code big voting 22
and I can't thank you enough for being
here let's continue with super chats we
are moments away from the eight o'clock
results which are going to give us some
sense of what's going on today uh people
saying I should also have an MSNBC live
feed let me try to do that
um
I I do what the people want okay
let's see if we can get the MSNBC live
feed here
task sort of for uh for Republicans this
is this give me a moment to adjust
again elected in that 2018. duplicate
Vega Republican Challenger now again
you're getting a lot of the same day
vote here so that is pushing that
Republican
this is a district I'll just show you
scene it's a district that Joe Biden won
by six points and then let me just
adjust it we're doing it on the Fly
folks Republicans to get this one you
know they they feel like on a normal
night they could get the second they
feel on a good night they could get the
seventh the night that they might have a
bit of a wave going on are people
preferring the MSNBC feed I'm glad to
stick with it whatever people want with
early vote being added to the mix and
also if you just look at where the vote
is coming in from so far the biggest
outstate the place that has no very very
good yet okay so we're watching
everything super super closely let's
look at a few more Super chats okay that
one I did
uh this is a good question mark asks
thank you for your coverage David how
important do you think elements of
bathrooms are well very strongly it
sinks and showers and you can do that
other thing normally all right the third
element of the bathroom
yep
elements of medical yep uh I don't think
sinks showers and toilets will be super
important today let me see if I can
adjust this a little bit more
uh because this is something about this
is not looking right to me there we go
this makes more sense
there we go that's much better okay
apologies guys apologies continuing on
I'm concerned about your audience your
poll had a huge number of votes saying
Democrats win House and Senate you're so
balanced and realistic yet somehow you
can't make Progressive see reality I'm
doing what I can
I'm doing what I can this is a little
glitchy I don't love how this is kind of
blinking
so that's weird let's see if I refresh
it if that goes away I'm not I'm not
thrilled with that
okay
now it's weird we might have to get away
from that Northern Illinois was in line
and a lady in front of me tried to vote
even though she voted early they asked
if she wanted to do a provisional ballot
but she stormed out I guess there isn't
a problem after all
David sir I want to stress local
elections are super important school
boards Etc of course they are it's just
a little bit out of the scope of what we
can cover
if Republicans take the house they will
surely investigate David's nearly
illegal discount codes absolutely I'm
ready
are you not monitoring truth social yeah
I mean maybe maybe we should uh just to
keep an eye on what Trump says and does
I think Trump's already oh should we do
the voter fraud stuff I guess we should
um Trump and others are already calling
it voter fraud
uh here we go
oh God what is this
Maricopa County in particular don't
leave your line stay where you are they
say that the machines aren't working
they say that they're running out of
paper in different locations throughout
different states there's a lot of bad
things going on over 54 countries have
now been taken by the machines stay
online do not leave online is a very New
York City thing no you don't want to be
there as long as is they're going to try
and force you they want to delay you out
of voting and you cannot let them delay
you out of voting so to the people of
Arizona in particular because that's the
one that's come up right now stay online
don't leave stay on the line and in it
yeah they're they're doing a lot of this
stuff here is they're focused in very
very strongly on Arizona here's Charlie
Kirk saying if Blake Master loses it
will be criminal I hope Steve I think
Carrie Lake's going to be just fine I
think Blake is in the fight for his life
but I'm telling you right now if Blake
Masters loses by 5 000 or 10 000 votes
it'll be because of the voter
suppression by Design because of Bill
Gates and Stephen Richards so can you
can you imagine I hope those people at
the Maricopa County Recorder's Office I
hope they have some explanation this is
stuff isn't Maricopa County run by by
Republicans
we're going to look into that for
tomorrow
um here's Brett Baier with a little bit
of oh it's it's a little bit strange
what's going on there we kind of knew
you know I mean
how about how about we fix the machines
I mean why is this happening can we get
our head around there are going to be
problems all over the country some
problems but
for it to happen here for it to happen
now in this way is kind of strange so
all right and here's Charlie Kirk two
hour weight minimum at most polling
places in Maricopa Democrats running
elections here knew it would happen
traffic jam by Design don't let them do
2020 again wait in line and vote
um I'm pretty sure Republicans run
Maricopa County
but we're gonna have all of the answers
we're going to have all of the answers
by tomorrow uh don't don't fret for even
a moment we have nine minutes to go
until we have some very significant poll
closings which will allow a significant
insight into the results I'd like to
check in with Fox and Newsmax to see how
they're reacting hello to Clay and Sam
who are watching tonight yeah I mean
let's just take a quick look at what's
happening on Fox News oh Maria Bartiromo
dear God
2016. late in the night you made a lot
of money you made a lot of money so
quickly Maria does the market like
divided government the market does like
divided government
um and that's what we're likely to see
if idiotic analysis uh look at the
history
um
every economic indicator is stronger
under a Democratic president
the correlation to Senate and House has
not been established
these people are just feeding pablum to
their low information audience I hate to
tell you
David sir just want to say you're the
you just political Politico I follow
user than China but they're losers very
bad people very bad although I did win
you saw me say China keep it up my
friend thank you Discman the only thing
I agree with Republicans is the crime
rate are Democrats going to get tougher
on crime other than that the right is
crazy well Todd explain exactly what you
mean because for all the talk about New
York Oklahoma has a higher violent and
property crime rate than New York State
Oklahoma City has a higher
um violent and property crime rate than
New York city so what exactly are you
talking about Todd I want to hear
specifically what exactly
are you talking about
I want to say thank you to one two three
four five six seven eight nine 10 11 12
13 and 14 people who just signed up for
memberships on my website putting us at
12 22. folks
this is the start of maybe the most
insane two-year political period we will
have seen during my career
we do need to build support for the
left-wing media ecosystem I want to say
thanks to kingsman
straight man renounce uh for the twitch
Prime subscriptions and yes if you go to
joinpakman.com you can use the code big
voting22 you get a discount we fill this
bar up to 1500 and it's going to be a
Bonkers evening a Bonkers evening let's
listen to Just One voicemail just one
voicemail
uh and see what is on people's minds
today hey David uh for the first time
ever in my voting life I'm 69 years old
so that's a lot I voted early beautiful
okay and good news I had to stand in
line for a long time to vote early
people are voting early okay which is
good so it's uh but usually most of the
people who vote early are Democrats yeah
I don't know if that's the case this
time around but we're of course going to
keep an eye on it we do have a voicemail
from Whitney and I can't think of a more
important person to hear from on such an
important day
oh it's just background noise
all right well too bad I think Whitney
tried to call in and unfortunately we
just got background noise okay that's uh
that's it s Prez has just dumped in
another 100 twitch subscriptions and
thanks to dorky Von Munch Munch we are
at 1 326 and the 8 P.M close haven't
polls haven't even closed we have five
minutes until the next series of polls
close
do not go anywhere because we are about
to get a really important picture of
where tonight is going before that
happens let's just review
where we are right now starting with
starting with uh gubernatorial okay from
the standpoint of gubernatorial
in Ohio Mike dewine has won actually I
should probably refresh this I don't
know why Ohio is blue even though a
republican one it's very very strange
something seems to have glitched out
here
that is that is very weird
well that's a malfunction
uh let's go elsewhere
and this is just way behind so now we're
getting some delays in some of the data
which is extraordinarily weird let's
look at uh the New York Times okay maybe
maybe that's going to help us so
um looking at the senate in the New York
Times we see that uh
in Vermont Peter Welch has won
in New Hampshire Maggie Hassan is
fortunately leading in Kentucky it's
been called for Rand Paul in South
Carolina it's been called for Tim Scott
now here's where it gets interesting in
North Carolina with 42 percent of the
vote in Sherry Beasley is ahead of Ted
bud this is a critical critical critical
race absolutely critical race
in Georgia
just look at what's happening in Georgia
okay
let's wait and see in Ohio
very early remember that the polling
favors JP Mandel JD Vance in Ohio
very very early very early
small lead for Tim Ryan and in Florida
Marco Rubio is significantly ahead it's
almost over in Florida
would be almost impossible for Val
demmings to catch up okay and we are
about to get extremely important poll
closures in just a moment other super
chats are coming in
uh thanks to wait I already we already
did the blog live in the Arkansas live
in Arkansas the line has been over an
hour for several hours turnout is insane
interesting
I'm in Maricopa County says Quimby
dropped off our votes at the city hall
police station Dropbox no problems sick
of Arizona being the center of all Maga
conspiracy I know it's horrifying
this country we're going to lose its
so-called Freedom someone told me what
woke means I showed them the right
definition told me I was lying even with
a link to it and he gave me no linger
citation yeah it's bad out there MK
I'm in Nevada error came up with a
printing issue don't they needed paper
as a receipt if they need recount can
you explain how they track my vote I I
don't know what's going on in Nevada
specifically I I'm I'm I don't know
exactly the system that they use
uh thank you to Jeff in Boston who has
just gifted 10 subscriptions via twitch
also thanks to mushroom Gremlin and
Manny putting us at 1338
Bay photo says regardless of the outcome
I fear the tension and desire for
violence is only getting worse I fear
the same thing
I fear the same thing this is an
interesting race on the screen I've
interviewed J.R Majewski he is cuckoo
for Coco Puffs very dangerous candidate
and uh I believe that he's actually
polling quite well only one percent
reporting Marcy captor is up let's hope
she wins she is the incumbent would be
horrible if Majewski wins that
Pennsylvania Supreme Court pulled a
last-minute voter suppression game with
mail-in ballots covered it on the show
today
covered it on the show today
David thank you your show brings me a
sliver of Sanity in the hellscape
Florida has become
sir I had a small conversation on social
media with the Eggman Shalom to you both
well thank you all right 38 seconds
until some major projections let's
listen just quickly uh moving over here
the United States Senate I just want to
make the point because it's the very
same Dynamic this is a big deal okay
here we go the Democratic candidate Tim
Ryan is out to an early lead here in the
state of Ohio but this is again a 100 at
least as of two minutes ago 100 early
vote you'd rather be ahead than behind
but we're waiting you see the middle
part here that's gray not filled in that
is Trump country in Ohio Jake we'll
watch the races everybody relax as we
move through the hour
all right John King we are just moments
away from the biggest round of poll
closings this evening including that
critical Senate contest and the great
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania that could
go a long way toward deciding control of
the U.S here we go as of right now CNN
is projecting that Senator Marco Rubio
the Republican from Florida will be
re-elected as expected congresswoman Val
demings in Alabama CNN is projecting
that Katie Britt will win her senate
seat defeating uh her opponent she is a
former staffer for the retiring
Republican uh dick Shelby in that
Alabama senate seat so that's a hold for
republicans in Oklahoma CNN is
projecting that incumbent Senator James
Lankford will win in the special
election in Oklahoma CNN is projecting
that Mark Wayne Mullen will be elected
defeating Kendra horn and then in
Kentucky with CNN is projecting that
incumbent Republican senator Rand Paul
all expected did so far folks everybody
relax Chase in Pennsylvania CNN is
declaring to be too early to call and
the big Senate race that's between uh
Lieutenant Lieutenant Governor John
Federman and TV's Dr mehmed Oz too early
to call as of right now and in New
Hampshire a competitive race between
incumbent Democratic senator Maggie
Hassan against retired General Don
Bolduc again too early to call let's
look at the map in general right now
right now we have no projection in
Connecticut Illinois Maryland Missouri
and then as I said New Hampshire and
Pennsylvania too early to call right now
the overall balance of power in the U.S
Senate Democrats have 36 of the Senate
seats Republicans have 35. so more that
is not known right now than is known for
people saying in the chat not looking
good everything so far is as expected so
I mean listen I'll I'll tell you when
it's time to panic do you guys were you
how many of you were with me in November
of 2020 oh hold on here's a projection
DeSantis okay we knew about it fine we
knew about it not it's all expected
remember when I said I'll let you know
when it's time to panic and there was
like an hour during which I was saying
now it's time to panic but then I said
actually it's not time to panic and then
Biden won okay and I'm punching the mic
and everything
so far is as expected
everything so far is as expected there's
no surprises here so far
okay so plenty of time plenty plenty
plenty of time
[Music]
um
what size dumps am I expecting asks Kyle
they're going to be huge they're going
to be huge
took me less than five minutes to vote
in East Boston today can't believe all
the lines in red States why would anyone
want to make it harder to vote well if
you want if you're Republican and you
want to win make it hard to vote in
Democratic leaning areas I mean it's
classic voter suppression as you can see
the numbers in Georgia are tightening
exactly as expected I said it was way
too early to glean anything about that
race Kemp was leading handily in the
polling we're at 31 reporting a race
that we're going to watch a race that
we're going to watch okay
sir I've moved from the pit that is
Florida and I'm watching you in Southern
England says Charissa keep up the good
work well thank you very much
the good Liars have a new video who with
a woman who admitted to voting for Trump
twice in 2020. oh let's let's find that
good liars Twitter
let's see
ah yes here it is
oh check this out this this is
unbelievable these these people are
truly unbelievable
you ever seen any voter fraud yeah me I
did it you you you committed voter fraud
what'd you do voter's wife or Trump
really four years ago yes did you get in
trouble for that yeah
yeah really yeah yeah now if I voted for
Hillary I would have got a gold medal
but you voted for Trump twice yes I did
yeah yeah so I learned the hard way not
to do it but did you wear a mustache or
anything no
no one time like maybe a couple of
player Crown voted another place
someplace else I don't know I'm having
like a big crisis because I honestly
thought it was like libs that were doing
it yeah
yeah
hmm
very very interesting huh very very
compelling compelling stuff
uh
there's a lady with upper management
written all over her that's for damn
sure
that is for damn sure
uh any interest in reviewing Shapiro's
appearance on Lex Friedman podcast thank
you for covering midterms Destiny would
never Obama
ship which Shapiro Ben Shapiro I don't
even know who who is on there
Ben Shapiro Lex Friedman is that what it
was
um
nah I I'm not super interested in that
to be totally honest
thank you for everything you do as a
public educator I admire your efforts in
educating our nation with empirical
evidence and research-backed positions
thank you Marion Iowa a lot of young
folks and females not getting my hopes
up wouldn't it be nice if Grassley was
retired
happy two-year anniversary discovered
you election night 2020 have been a
member ever since thanks industry
David sir today is my birthday a nice
birthday gift gift is for Walker Oz and
Lake Toulouse Also let's see if you
pronounce my name right rohane Hamilton
rohane Hamilton geez I don't know David
how about checking in on vash's stream
for a quick dual stream always goodbye
yeah I don't have any way of like
getting a hold of him right now I don't
think
always appreciate watching your patient
coverage of Elections both in the 2020
General like you said but also in the
primary when you didn't pretend Bernie
was in it when he wasn't no I I'm not
going to bamboozle you guys that is
something I'm not going to do thank you
to the nine people who just signed up on
my website putting us at 1347.
s Prez has just dumped in a hundred
subscriptions via folks look at where we
are
geostigma just gifted five
Sid Ki and jacala just signed up
we are at
1454 ladies and gentlemen we may do
something we have never ever done before
not defeat Herschel Walker which
hopefully we will do
but these are absolutely stunning
stunning numbers I'm forced to believe
there are too many delusional people to
deal with I'm going to move to a
desolate Island who's in
that's many are saying that Joey but
let's let's wait and see okay
Tim says Ohio viewer here love the show
encouraged everyone I saw today on my
college campus to vote told everyone
where they can find their polling place
seeing Tim Ryan leading right now brings
me some Joy it's very very early folks
very very early
David why don't people like Bill Gates
Soros Etc Sue Tucker Charlie Kirk and
others for defamation seems like an easy
win it's tough to win defamation cases
very tough check out my interview with
the plaintiff's lawyer in the Alex Jones
case Mark Bankston to understand why
at a Lindsay cross event in Florida at
least we'll have one win honestly bummed
out about all of it hoping for a change
of pace by 24. I'm with you Caitlyn
David they're saying my home county
Miami-Dade might go red what are your
thoughts we'll get the data we we will
get the data as it comes in
how are you don't forget to hydrate ah
yes I have my water here beautiful water
oh God what is that that's horrible no
it's beautiful beautiful water okay
let's take a look at the latest uh at
the latest numbers okay because I do
want to get a little bit of an update
this is the CNN panel CNN panel starting
with governors in Texas it is very early
nine percent of the vote in
overwhelmingly from Dallas Texas
it would be beautiful if Beto could win
it's very early I will tell you
when we can start to have some
confidence in that not yet
Florida has been called for Ron DeSantis
Ron DeSantis re-elected Georgia
extremely early numbers extremely early
numbers Stacy Abrams is plus about two
and a half super early way way way way
way too early okay don't make anything
of it quite yet
South Carolina
McMaster up quite a bit but it is still
early
Pennsylvania we are all watching it
with only three percent of the vote in
folks it's really early it's Shapiro
Plus 78.
do not take those numbers to the bank
do not take those numbers to the back
they are beautiful numbers but we're
talking about three percent it's all
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania is going to be
long
it's going to be wide okay
let's let's wait on that one
but it is an interesting early result
Ohio has been called for Mike dewine the
incumbent no surprise we were expecting
that
um and then we are watching the
gubernatorial race in New Hampshire
which is very very close very very close
okay that is gubernatorial gubernatorial
going now to the senate in the Senate we
are starting to get some interesting
numbers let's go to the most important
and interesting races immediately in the
State of Florida Marco Rubio has won
re-election it's over it's over it's
over okay that's it we expected Rubio to
win he was very far ahead in the polls
Georgia is of extraordinary interest
extraordinary interest right now we have
36 percent of the voting
I'm not going to ignore the fact that
Raphael Warnock is plus 10 over Herschel
Walker who cannot even speak
can't speak can't explain his positions
on any issue it's early as you can see
voting concentrated in Augusta Atlanta
Columbus and Savannah the city vote
expected to go to Rafael Warnock
okay
so we're taking it easy there very
interesting race in North Carolina okay
half the vote is in the Democrat Beasley
is Plus 10.
okay
very very important oh
that's a good idea so let's compare
so this is actually very interesting
Camp has 719 000 votes so far in Georgia
and with the same 37 percent Walker has
only 650 000 votes so among the first 36
37 percent
there appear to be 70 000 people
who voted for kemp but not Walker
that's a good sign for Raphael Warnock
it's just a data point at 8 11 pm in the
East it's just a data point
okay
um as I mentioned it would be amazing if
Ted Budd could be defeated half the vote
is in he's losing by 10. that's a datum
a datum okay important
in Ohio
it is only 23 of the vote it over
represents early and mail-in voting
okay
Ryan Plus 15.
that it's not going to stay that way it
is not going to stay that way
but we are watching it and then of
course in Pennsylvania
so early these are flushable numbers
these these aren't going to tell us
anything so early five percent of the
vote in it's Pittsburgh Philly and
Harrisburg okay
don't I mean folks just it's 8 12 okay
fetterman plus 71. I'll say it out loud
but it's just so so so early that it is
not worth getting all riled up about uh
we know that Tim Scott has already won
re-election in South Carolina totally
expected not a huge deal we know that
Rand Paul has won re-election in
Kentucky completely expected in Indiana
young is leading he's the incumbent
expecting expecting him to win there
um in Missouri Missouri is kind of an
interesting race uh Bush Valentine is
not a very good Democratic candidate and
she is down significantly but it is very
very early almost no none of the vote
has been counted in Kansas uh Moran is
the incumbent expected to win this isn't
a shock uh what you have to understand
when you look at a map and you see red
most of these races are not competitive
and they're not expected to make a
difference
and then Oklahoma
Lankford already won re-election
actually do we have gubernatorial
numbers in Oklahoma I want to take a
look at that
uh super super early Kevin's tit is the
incumbent and he is down a little bit
this is so early it would be amazing if
Hofmeister could win she's actually not
bad at all uh but this is just so so
early Kevin's tit
expected to win there and then you know
in the house in the house it's more of
like a big picture so far Republicans
have picked up three seats that's really
the number that matters that's the the
important number plus three for
Republicans Republicans are expected to
take control of the house everything
continues to point in that direction so
that's the lay of the land right now I
the the way I would put it right now is
there are opportunities here there are
opportunities here for Democrats
um nothing yet people are asking for
Massachusetts nothing yet
but I assume Healy is easily going to
win
uh incumbent McKee in Rhode Island
expected to hold very very early not
much of the vote in we're getting our
first vote dump from Michigan with only
two percent reporting Gretchen Whitmer
the incumbent is plus 60 not six that's
60 over Maga Tudor Dixon Maga Tudor
Dixon
I'm not ready to call it yet it's only
two percent of the vote but we are
getting our first vote dumps there which
I am I am glad to see and let's just
briefly get updated numbers from Texas
with 16 percent of the vote in Beto is
still doing fine but look at the map
it's Dallas and Austin these are super
blue areas super super blue areas I
don't want you
making any assessments based on these
data yet let's check in on Fox news and
see what they're talking about uh whoops
Let's uh
make sure this is all good for you guys
see where the vote comes in throughout
the night the three C's guys Cincinnati
Columbus and Cleveland I could go on for
about three more hours but my time is up
because they told me to wrap three times
oh thanks Bill you're so you're so
Whimsical they tell you to rap and you
just keep talking you're so so so
whimsical
okay let's reset as we anticipate more
data first and foremost first and
foremost
where are we on thanking incredible
people Jake thurches Chelsea Smurfy Taw
and actual one have grabbed some
memberships via twitch Prime folks let's
get to 2500 on Twitch we're at 1974. I
also want to say thank you to the three
people great people who just grabbed
memberships on my website I wanna if
you're new here okay
it is of such critical importance that
we set up
Independent Media to be ready for these
next two years my only real request is
make sure you're subscribed on our on
our YouTube channel it is completely
free that's the number of subscribers it
costs nothing hit the Subscribe button
We Believe three quarters of the people
watching right now aren't subscribers
that's like seven thousand we could get
over these numbers instantly we're going
to be here for Trump's announcement next
Tuesday we're going to be here for the
entire thing the primary all of it all
of it all of it same thing applies if
you are watching us on Twitch it's it's
just free folks it's just free to
subscribe okay oh look at that thank you
very much appreciate that we're gonna
watch all these numbers super closely
at some point
if the left wants to compete with the
right when it comes to Independent Media
we're going to have to support some
shows
I don't need you to support this show
although I would love it if you did okay
and the easiest way to do that is simply
to go to joinpakman.com
I won't spend a lot of time on this you
hit the sign up button we have the
coupon code big voting 22 available okay
big voting 22. you type it in you get a
discount
if you want an even bigger discount you
use the coupon code obamna
okay you type that in discounts even
bigger this is you know the right does
it the right they support Charlie Kirk
they support all these different people
free ways to support paid ways to
support we appreciate all of it people
are dumping in super chats which I'm
gonna get to thanks to Rockstar farmer
with a 50 Super Chat says sir do you
know when the massive dumps are
scheduled 9 p.m are the next big vote
dumps but they're continuing to come in
12 minutes from now bottom of the hour
we're going to check in about all of it
okay let me see if very quickly I'm
gonna jump on my Discord real real fast
just to see if we can check in with some
of the other great people that are
covering the election today
uh and then we're gonna have continued
let me let me just see here
let me check in with varsh Ian varsh
and see where he's at
um
let me check in with Destiny
and let me check in with Hassan
okay let's see who gets back to me first
I have connect I have sent messages to
Ian vosh
Stephen Kenneth Destiny benell II and
Hassan
[ __ ]
okay let's see if any of them get back
to me for a very quick check-in about
these results and these data
okay thank you very much
um
other super chats if you want to support
Progressive media put your money where
your mouth is and give Sam Cedar his
panels back oh our new studio is almost
almost done
the panels are going to be
ritualistically burned and done away
with it's going to be absolutely
fantastic it's going to be absolutely
fantastic
um
one moment that okay vosh wants to
connect
Bosch wants to connect
beautiful
uh vosh twitch is Bosh on Twitch
he's not even live what's going on
oh he's on YouTube
oh he's been oh I can't even have him on
then right
oh God hold on close wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa
am I not allowed to have them on because
he's banned on Twitch he's not banned
let me just check
you aren't banned on Twitch right
oh right he's not banned I was just
looking at it okay okay
boss YouTube
okay
all right good good good so we're going
to hear from vosh momentarily thank you
very much
uh
here's vosh okay hold on
let's get everything set up correctly
let me get my all of my stuff here howdy
is this Ian vosh
it is Ian vosh kochinski yes welcome to
the program my friend
yes it's been a good long while have you
been yeah I've I've been well what are
you I'm guessing you know people have
been reporting to me that while you're
and my political views differ we both
agree that tonight it would be better if
Republicans didn't win everything and
send us off a cliff of dystopian
authoritarianism and vote stealing and
election stealing into 2024 do I
understand that correctly yeah it's a
tough sell but they just really haven't
got me on board with the aforementioned
totalitarian uh fascist agenda yes I
know
any particular race you're looking at
um I I think I've just kind of blearily
looking at the entire thing with my eyes
kind of like fuzzing out I think there
there are so many that I've looked at on
the off time that it's difficult to
concentrate I mean probably Warnock
feels like the most yeah immediately
um gripping race I guess yeah and we
were just looking at the latest numbers
there
it's Warnock plus eight and like the
lead is shrinking every time they count
more vote every time there's more vote
dumps for lack of a better term I think
it'll end up being really close I don't
know who's going to win but I think it's
going to be way closer than these
numbers
another goddamn runoff
that's another concern yeah because of
this Oliver guy I mean warnocks
warnock's above 50 for now but uh we'll
we'll see we'll see if we can avoid that
how are you kind of thinking about the
next two years by the way if people are
just joining us joining us we are
speaking with vosh are I'm thinking of
the next two years as most likely
controlling the house and potentially
some critical Governors houses
Republicans are going to set themselves
up to try to get the next president to
be a republican whether that candidate
actually wins or not in 2024 like it
seems that's fundamentally what this is
about
yeah have you um kept up at all with the
Moore versus Harper upcoming Supreme
Court decision to some degree I have
yeah yeah I think my answer really
depends on how that one goes it seems
like they're going to validate the
independent state legislature Doctrine
which if they do it feels like elections
sort of become irrelevant at least at a
federal level there are enough
Republican state legislators that they
could rework the rules internally to the
point where between the Senate house and
uh elector count they could kind of
reliably make Federal elections
unwinnable for um for the Democrats so I
think most of my coverage at this point
I think is sort of like a very very like
um 1950s Duck and Cover propaganda like
what do you do if your country is
descending into Fascism and try trying
to work on that mostly a lot of my
viewers have been saying should I leave
the country if XYZ and the first thing I
explained to a lot of them is it's
actually pretty hard to go to most of
the places you would probably want to
move to that's number one but also
there's this thing of like okay at a
certain point like I have friends in
Arizona and they're horrified about the
possibility that Kerry Lake will win
they currently have embryos on Ice
they're worried about Reproductive
Rights you know all these concerns so
it's sort of like well if Kerry Lake
wins do you just bail and go to a blue
state but then it that probably only
makes the red States even more dystopian
so is the right move to stay and try to
fix the red States I don't know
yeah I think I mean the issue is it
seems like this is quickly becoming
inconsequential right they've been doing
gerrymandering for decades to the point
where they have very effectively like
despite being a minority of the country
maintained an adversarial like sometimes
even a lead
um when it comes to electoral results I
don't know if there's actually any
outcome difference between like staying
in the state or moving to another state
I don't know if staying in a blue state
will make you that much safer given a
long enough time frame I don't know
let's talk about that for a second oh
sure yeah I do agree that on the one
hand there are certain things that it
doesn't matter what state you're in
you're sort of subject to disasters that
are potentially implemented at uh
federally but for example I don't know
if you've ever looked at like HDI
equivalencies in states where you just
rank states by human development index
the way you might rank countries
the top 15 or so states in the U.S by
HDI which is like a blended metric that
includes life expectancy you know all
these different things education Etc
the top 15 or so states in the U.S are
like the European countries that you and
I probably consider the better places to
live in
on the other hand
if you go to Mississippi and Alabama the
states with the low hdis are mostly like
countries most of us would not consider
great places to live like Syria there's
a really material difference between
living in in on average blue and red
states that I think does make a
difference people to People's day-to-day
lives
oh no I absolutely agree for now yeah
I'm wondering to what extent that'll
persist especially in certain regards so
like for example you and I are media
guys you know yes and I don't want to
fear-monger or anything but generally
speaking when Federal control is gained
by fascists one of the first things they
do is Target opposition and if you
control you know the house the Senate
the presidency and the court it wouldn't
be that difficult to crack out a couple
of laws on like uh dissent or you ought
to call it like uh the propagandistic
Un-American whatever you know it's
pretty easy to get the right people
quickly
um when they have that power now if
you're like a regular Joe like an
average person in the United States like
you you there's no reason you'd have a
Target over your head yeah I think you
should try to maximize your own
well-being I don't think it's fair
especially like man imagine like you set
up to live in like Alabama in the vain
hope that one day it flips blue or
something and then you have a kid and
that kid ends up being gay and it's like
well like so much it's human misery you
know I don't know if that's a good like
long-term strategy no I agree and
especially now you know having a having
a baby I don't know if you did you know
I had a baby yeah and congratulations
thank you by the way especially with
that now the idea of like sticking it
out someplace that sucks and where like
things would be worse for my kid because
it sort of feels like the right thing to
do it it's sort of like it's not gonna
happen you know you know what I mean
it's it's we we have these limited
lifespans and the idea of saying well
I'm going to subject my kid to a
horrible right-wing dystopia because I
kind of like hope that it's better in 20
years it's just a no you know I don't
know how else to say it it's pretty
regionally biased too right if you
already live in California and it's like
oh well why not move over to Utah and
make it better well [ __ ] why not move
over to like Syria to make it better
like you know technically a highly
educated relatively wealthy Progressive
you know American in like Bangladesh
would probably have a pretty outside
eyes effect in their local political you
know um yeah so but like no obviously we
can't do that we can't we're not like
liquids that fill a container report
into you know we're going to live where
we're comfortable
um I just I'm more concerned with like
in the long run like how do we get
our communities or or or as many
Americans as possible like how do you
tell them like to knuckle down and get
ready for what might be like a proper
end to our democracy because a lot of
them are going to survive it but that
doesn't necessarily mean they're going
to have a great time during it you know
no absolutely for sure and in particular
you know with the Confluence of what's
Happening Here which is it's the policy
stuff like the views on Reproductive
Rights and uh non-discrimination and the
rights of it's that and then it's also
like they don't really seem to have much
of a problem with the candidate that
gets fewer votes assuming power and so
it's sort of it's not just issue
oriented like at one point it was just
about like oh education is better or
worse here versus there and increasingly
now it's it's so much broader than that
and it comes down to just like do you
even generally believe that the will of
the people should Prevail the answer is
increasingly no and I feel bad for
people that are that are in a lot of
these parts of the country
yeah and
um yeah it's really difficult because
interpersonally and like politically
these environments can feel really
different I've been to the South enough
to know that people who would probably
vote to have me put in a camp for liking
men would probably also if I just hung
out with them for a day be really really
friendly even if they knew that I was
interested in men so the experience of
like the outsized political effects of
these groups versus knowing them
interpersonally it can make it really
difficult to know
where a person should live to be safe
um I don't know if there are any easy
answers there it's just unfortunate
because it feels like we we've kind of
run out the the clock on electoral
viability when it comes to pushing back
against this without them they're just
not as underhanded as the Republicans
are without a doubt and you know the the
entire Michelle Obama like when they go
low we go high sort of thing I I think
that there's two categories here where
on the one side there are absolutely
tactics that I would never want to stoop
to in order to win even if you can
justify the ends which is you're
preventing absolutely depraved horrible
people from taking power and so you know
ver certain types of of dishonesty and
lying criminality manipulating voting
machines although it's just no we we
just absolutely shouldn't do that on the
other hand some of the stuff like using
slogans and framing that are you know
not completely accurate all this other
stuff it's like we absolutely need to be
better and and they pour money into a
lot of this stuff and the left doesn't
and the left loses as a result
oh yeah it's the you know when when
things go down as bad as they're going
to Democrat abstiniousness is going to
be one of those like historical Tut
lessons people are learning about in the
future you know because this really
makes like the the social Democrats in
Weimar it really gives them a run for
their money right Republicans have been
so open
in so many ways but like very clearly
like democracy means nothing to us we
will scrape every bit of power we can
until we no longer need to scrape and
it's just ours they've been screaming
that from the rooftops for a long time
now and I agree with you there are
limits to which you should not stoop for
a variety of reasons just like even from
like a rule utilitarian perspective
um but the Democrats are so far away
from that line like there are so many
things they could have done no matter
what reputation it would have earned
them if they brought out like sedition
trials for people associated with Jan 6
the same way like or Lincoln ousted
Confederate sympathetic like Senators
back when the Civil War began there are
so many like hard lines that could have
been taken that seem insane now but [ __ ]
it two years from now when things really
start rolling they will seem like
moderate responses compared to what it
would have prevented is there anything
you specifically
are doing as a result of the way things
have gone since they you know tried to
steal it in 2020 and then rioted on
January 6th like for example I have lots
of liberal friends that have either
started to or increased their gun
ownership by getting more guns or
starting to get their first guns people
that have moved to different states so
you know whatever whatever it is like
are you doing anything differently I
bought a lot of guns you own a lot of
guns now yeah
um I was gifted some of them by my very
conservative grandfather who doesn't
know what I do either so I have also
strategically disarmed the opposition
um you know I keep my passport up to
date uh I think I think everyone should
do the same it's it's really difficult
because like I mean you have to accept
like none of us are revolutionaries I
certainly am not um the idea of like oh
yeah things get really bad I'm gonna
fight back but like that's not really a
realistic mindset I think one of the
strongest things that a person can do in
a situation like this is to form strong
Community bonds because especially in
deep liberal cities the worst thing that
could happen there is like occupation
from right-wing militias like what we
saw during BLM there were those Patriot
prayer guys yep with the uh the guns and
the truck beds and they would like go
through the city and the difference in
terms of their ability to like occupy a
liberal neighborhood with a liberal
neighborhood being completely unarmed
and not being completely unarmed
different worlds and I'm kind of hoping
that might maintain like it might
prevent civil instability from leading
to like a lot of unnecessary death in
some areas I if it comes to that I don't
know it's really it's really tough do
you want guns by the way you know I
don't I don't talk about whether I own
guns interestingly that's fair yeah I
don't know I don't know why it just like
kind of I don't I don't know I mean I've
said before like my views on gun safety
regulation
are widely known by my audience and I've
also said the idea that like even
knowing all of the statistics about
Firearms the idea that only the right
has guns is unappealing to me but I just
kind of like don't mention anything
about my personal ownership or lack
thereof
no I that's good keep keep them uh keep
them guessing it is it is an issue right
because because people have always joked
like um oh yeah owning guns what is that
going to do against the military well
it's not the the far right like prepper
guys haven't been massing an Arsenal to
fight the military they've been massing
an Arsenal to fight us right the
military what they're hoping is it'll
either side with them or remain neutral
or to
um uh politically combative or too
internally divided to really do anything
meanwhile if in a non-military situation
the right would just sweep the country
with like no problems a couple of
far-right militias would be enough to
single-handedly hold down cities with
millions of left-leaning people yep no
without without a doubt and many of my
liberal friends feel that way and
they're like Hey listen I want to have
guns I want to have to go through an
extensive process to get them I think
everybody should have to go through that
process
but I'm not going to seed that and it's
sort of similar similar to what you're
saying
um how late you streaming today
I'm probably going to go to at least
eight tonight I'm going to keep going
for as long as there's any question
about the results of these votes which I
imagine will take a couple of days in
some races yep I um I find that this is
more of a cultural exercise than
anything because a lot of it is about
direction right like what do you do
after Dems lose to Reagan back in you
know like 80 or something right yeah
better luck next time
um we might we we might not get it next
time so
so I ask you
um
you know knowing knowing things as they
are what's on the table what have you
been talking about I mean beyond the
individual races like when you look
forward to the future what do you see I
I see tonight or this election whenever
the results are known as a potential
inflection point where there's the story
that up until now has been going back to
the Civil Rights era the Republican
party has become increasingly cartoonish
and extreme and divorced from policy and
you know we go through the whole story
where it's it's Gingrich in 94 and then
Bush and then Obama uh sort of coalesces
moreover racism and xenophobia and then
Trump and then okay then they tried to
take it in 2020. the inflection point
now is
was Biden in 2020 a permanent turning
away from the cliff and things will kind
of slowly normalize a little bit where
we get back in the direction of
democracy or is this the inflection
point where Republicans set themselves
up to genuinely just steal an election
in 24 and it's an inflection point in
the completely opposite direction I like
I think it's potentially that
significant of an inflection point
I don't disagree with you well whatever
you end up doing just remember and you
know I don't want to be negative or
anything but no when things get really
bad people like you and I are literally
the first they go after so wow okay
let's get really bad I uh even just
catch you in the uh International part
of me going through right now re-upping
and revalidating and renewing all of my
Argentinian documents is in order to get
my daughter citizenship but I think it
would be a good idea to be doing it
regardless I mean what why not it's not
like things are so great in Argentina in
fact the economy is a total disaster but
it just seems like options are good
yeah it's uh there's never been a better
time to have dual citizenship right
right
and you know listen I mean there's
always Israel if it really came to it
for me yeah I don't know if they'd let
me on I can't join you on that flight
but yeah that's anyone you can take with
how Netanyahu is going right now with
the coalition government he's building
who know it could end up being just as
bad
um without a doubt I
I wish you safety yeah thank you
likewise all right we'll check in soon
great catching up with you take care all
right there he is Ian vosh ladies and
gentlemen world famous Ian vosh Destiny
said he's busy on a panel with Lauren
Chen Blair white and Sean ajw and I can
join if I want but that's that's a no
for me and then Hassan did not even
write back so I think we're too little
at this point for Hassan
so that's what's going on okay let's get
reoriented here in terms of the numbers
and reset it is election night in
America I am so glad that you are here
with me right now because we have so
many important things to do
um where do I even start let's start
with some of the results and we will go
first to gubernatorial important races
here Michigan is one we've been looking
at closely with four percent of the vote
in it's two to one Gretchen Whitmer over
magat uh Tudor Dixon good good news very
very early okay Whitmer is expected to
win by about 10.
uh Massachusetts not really a shock but
Maura Healy ahead of Jeff deal roughly
two to one will probably be called
relatively soon
what about Pennsylvania Pennsylvania is
a critical critical race
this nine percent of the vote which is
plus 74 Josh Shapiro
is a lot of
um early votes and City votes as you can
see Pittsburgh
Harrisburg Philly so Shapiro is expected
to win by somewhere between 8 and 10 but
it is very very early
um Michael says I appreciate it when you
refer to epistemology and media literacy
can you spare five minutes and speak
about one of them
not tonight Michael we I've I mean I
don't know what I would say in the
abstract but we have a white paper
coming out about how to employ them in
conversations with people very very soon
it's going to be free okay
um Georgia gubernatorial as expected
Brian Kemp has taken the lead that early
data that had Stacey Abrams ahead I said
be very skeptical of that
um the polling is Camp is probably going
to win so we are seeing that there
super interesting that the incumbent
governor in Oklahoma Kevin's tit is not
ahead but I do believe he will
ultimately win I think this reflects a
lot of early and mail-in boat
and then again not surprising the
numbers have flipped to Greg Abbott the
incumbent Republican governor in Texas
Beto was losing
and
I mean listen it would be a shock if
Beto won I hope he does I hope he does
but that would that would really come as
a shock
um I guess we'll look at Illinois
pritzker is ahead he's the incumbent
he's expected to win not a big shock
there not a big shock but okay that's
gubernatorial let's let's now take a
look at Senate races of course one of
the critical Senate races is fetterman V
Oz it is super early super early but
it's fetterman plus 65 right now
we got to give this at least two more
hours
it's so so so early
um in Ohio that's a really important
race Ryan Vance JD Vance was projected
to win we have a third of the vote in
still over representing early mail-in
and City votes and Tim Ryan is up 11.
we're holding out hope but it's just
it's an uphill battle
um and then Georgia
it is tightening exactly as I said it
would in Georgia Raphael Warnock is
still ahead but it's only 4.3 47 percent
of the vote is in
and we could not possibly be watching
that anymore closely we are also really
interested in the race in North Carolina
Beasley jumped out to an early lead I
don't believe
that uh she was expected to win and with
58 of the vote she's holding on to a
four-point lead but Bud May well be be
surging there uh as you can see
Asheville Durham rally Charlotte uh
Wilmington Fayetteville these are cities
in North Carolina Early vote came from
cities and that helped Beasley we don't
know exactly where it is going to go
um Alabama already called for Brit as
expected no no surprise there
good news in New Hampshire for a second
it looked like maybe Bolduc might have a
shot but uh Maggie Hassan the incumbent
one not not a big surprise in Vermont uh
Welch has defeated no has no it has not
been called yet sorry it's only 18 of
the vote I spoke too soon Welch leading
by 32 but still quite early
um
and then in the house the house is
tougher because there's just so many but
the important number is Republicans have
made three pickups so far so we're going
to continue watching all of that super
super closely all right if people will
allow me I want just a moment to get
everything caught back up if you're
joining me you have no idea who I am
that's fine I'm David packman I have a
YouTube channel podcast twitch stream
we're on nearly 200 radio and television
stations almost everything we produce is
free for everybody okay and there are so
many free ways you can support the work
that we're doing if you were watching
right now on YouTube okay if you're
watching right now on YouTube please
subscribe to my channel it's completely
free there's 13 000 people watching most
of you are not subscribed
look at these you'll see it reflected
right away okay also please like the
stream we have 2 000 likes but 56 000
different people have watched the stream
today two thousand fifty six thousand
cost you nothing to like cost you
nothing to subscribe same thing applies
if you were watching on Twitch if you're
watching on Twitch twitch make sure that
you're following uh and if you have uh
what's it called the Amazon Prime if you
have Amazon Prime you can
um use the Amazon Prime subscription to
get a twitch Prime subscription it's
free you're just taking money from Jeff
Bezos it's a beautiful beautiful thing
if you want to do a little bit more and
I believe that at least some of us
should
I would love for you to sign up on my
website
super easy
join pacman.com
you can use the coupon code Obama
and you get a huge discount people have
asked me David sir are you planning a
new coupon code depending on what the
results are and the answer is yes if
you're still with us two three four five
six seven eight nine hours from now
I'd better be sleeping nine hours from
now maybe my daughter has other plans
but I'd better be sleeping nine hours
from now
um there will be something coming up
later but I now just super super super
quickly
want to say thanks to the people who
have supported what we are doing already
uh and that includes one two three four
five folks we might do it six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen sixteen Seventeen
eighteen well this is this is crazy
33
and 13 is 46. ladies and gentlemen
we are
at 1509 we have never seen this happen
before
we are going for 2 000 folks thanks to
microactive M6 zinzano tenacious dust
asparagus fishnabu Bret Pro coffee
catastrophe the show go champer and Jeff
in Boston for the gift 20 people signing
up via twitch
actually it's two more fifteen Thirty
One
and C missile gifting five folks I can't
even keep up and I'm not gonna try it's
crazy what's happening and we have a
goal of getting to 2 000 new members in
conjunction with today's stream let's
get a few more Super chats in before we
come back for more results
Harrisburg PA me and my crew voted blue
this morning congratulations Adam nicely
done
sorry David my likes playlist is used
for music please accept this instead
welcome Josh great to have you thanks to
Daniel Denver says my power came back on
I was watching the show in my Plumbing
truck for heat and cell phone charge
definitely wasn't drinking beer as well
Denver Denver's been around for a long
time so great to have you here Denver so
great to have you really appreciate that
we are moments away from more results 12
minutes until we get more results the
glitchiness on that feed is crazy we'll
get back to CNN in a moment
do we want to hear briefly from Marco
let's listen
I was raised by parents that worked in
hotels like this well not like this they
had slot machines and stuff like that
but in Las Vegas my dad was a banquet
bartender in rooms like this my mother
was a maid she worked at Kmart they
worked hard and and you know their story
is really very typical of the American
story
frankly in any other nation in the world
I would probably be doing the same job
and there's nothing wrong with those
jobs
but what makes this nation so special
and unique is that is the one place on
Earth where people who work those jobs
like the people working here now can go
on to do other things but even if they
can't the one thing they can always do
is give their kids the chance to do all
the things they didn't
and I think this is an American story
that people anywhere in the everywhere
in the country would understand
Marco Rubio a big winner over Val
demings in Florida a huge not a big deal
this was expected uh Rubio was leading
all along he did win he won easily he
won by more than expected could it be a
sign about what is coming later tonight
I don't know all we can do is wait and
see we have results in 11 minutes we may
get some more definition the next polls
are closing in 11 minutes and it's going
to be of absolutely critical critical
critical importance Arizona
uh does Arizona close at nine because
now Arizona is two hours back because
they don't change the clocks Arizona may
be closing at nine and I'm very
interested in getting some of those
early Arizona numbers we really want to
see what's going on in Wisconsin with
Mandela Barnes and Ron Johnson that's
going to be a very interesting race we
are moments away moments away from
getting some of that data
um and that is of absolutely critical
critical critical importance
um sir my friend used coupon code Obama
to register someone came to take her
away yeah you got to be careful those
coupon codes are extreme
Corrine says thanks for streaming for
States like mine Louisiana what would it
take for them to turn blue
with New Orleans and our governor being
blue is it possible anything is possible
Corinne but I don't expect Louisiana to
be blue anytime soon
so God someone who uses the name fart
God I mean come on guys David I love the
coverage you avoid click bait
sensationalism and Report thank you from
cater tot thank you
not a surprise Florida remains red but I
saw Miami-Dade County flipped red
we will look at that
home from the pub at an unearthly hour
on the UK can't really tell how things
are going are the polls accurate or not
too early to tell too early to tell Sean
it's going to be a while
just re-signed up for a membership
through your beautiful website sir tears
in my eyes well thank you Chris
Florida elected a 25 year old
Congressman we will have time to look at
that we will
a thanks to three additional folks who
just signed up on my website putting us
at 1548 also thanks to gentlein crowd
birth birth Christopher vods noodle
snakes and moist kefta just gifted five
that's nine putting us at 1557. let's
listen to what's going on in Arizona
and so we're seeing the Republican
candidates who are expecting to really
have their voters come out today
tweeting again and again stay in line
Kerry Lake tweeting stay in line hold
the line they want as big of a turnout
as they can today now when these results
start to drop and we do not expect them
until another one hour and 10 minutes
polls do close in uh nine minutes now
when those results drop we are hearing
all the campaigns saying patience
patience we are hearing from U.S Senate
candidate uh Mark Kelly nominee Mark
Kelly saying whoever is leading tonight
may not be the winner that is the key it
is too early after that first drop so
all of these campaigns I'm just warning
you all Arizona is going to be a total
mess it's going to be a tote they're
already claiming fraud
um I I I have a pit in my stomach
knowing what we are going to have to
suffer through out of Arizona over the
next
days would be optimistic
potentially weeks if not guys we're
still suffering through the Arizona
stuff from the 2020 election you can't
even imagine what they're about to
subject us to
out of Arizona it's it's just stunning
stunning stuff uh okay let me take a
five we're gonna monitor the CNN
coverage I will be back with you for the
9 p.m results Wisconsin and more of the
central part of the state now obviously
he is trying to win a third term here
and with it he has brought implications
of what that would mean one it could
contribute to a change in power in the
Senate which means he would chair an
investigations committee and he is
always he has already said he is ready
to ramp up the number of Investigations
out of Congress on the other side of
things lieutenant governor Mandela
Barnes he has told us he is feeling very
good tonight he feels that they have
done everything they could do up to this
point and hearing from party leadership
in the state Democratic Leadership feel
that one thing that they're watching for
tonight is that absentee ballots will be
counted later they're traditionally
among the last ballots to be counted
here at Central accounting facilities
across the state so they are are
watching for a potential red Mirage and
then some of their support to come in
later in the night talking to Republican
leadership they're aware of it but they
say they feel good about what they've
seen on Election Day itself Jake all
right Omar Jimenez thank you so much
with Johnson campaign headquarters in
Wisconsin and we're taking a look at the
lay of the land in the U.S Senate uh and
we were just joking about what's going
on in Maryland right now uh tell
everybody a look at the map can be
deceiving early on in the night as we
count results as we've said uh just
quickly where kyung law and Omar were
about to get two of the most competitive
States in American politics when those
results start to flow in in Arizona and
Wisconsin but just to pop up you see the
state of Maryland is red right now Chris
Van Hollen is the Democratic incumbent
Chris Chaffee is his opponent it's 13 to
12. okay but again if you look at
watching at home and you're just passing
through quickly and you see the map read
that's why we want to explain it when we
see things like this uh we'll come back
to that one in 10 or 15 minutes and
we'll see if that holds up that would be
a big surprise but there are there are
uh the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania is
blue at the moment that's a republican
held senate seat at the moment North
Carolina is blue at the moment that's a
republican held senate seat today Ohio
is blue at the moment that is also a
republican held senate seat now as we
move later into the night people
watching at home we've been cautioning
you all night long please wait please
wait let's wait for more votes well
we're getting more votes but we're still
only at 37 percent of the vote so you're
still looking at disproportionately in
the state of Ohio early vote I just was
looking here a moment ago because this
is Tim Ryan's house district he's a
member of the House of Representatives
trying to run Statewide in a very
complicated red leaning State uh this is
his house district this is that base of
his house district it stretches out and
down a little bit early votes in there
33 percent running a big lead that's
what he needs to do obviously these are
the people who know him best this is his
Democratic base and you come up to
Cuyahoga County uh only 30 percent of
the vote in here uh 74 to 26 percent
that's a big deal right this again
Democratic base Cleveland and the
suburbs around it you move over here to
Lake County this will be interesting to
watch right this is blue at the end of
the night Tim Ryan is running very very
competitive because this gets more
Republican As you move out Lake County
in the suburbs he's ahead at the moment
but it's half of the vote and David
Kelly is going to join us in just a
second because disproportionately I
believe we're still looking at more
early votes than day of votes so right
now 37 percent of the vote in Ohio is in
and Tim Ryan is up with 37 and let's
bring in David challenge at the
Battlegrounds ask to tell us
David David tell us who this 37 is and
and what we're waiting for yeah so you
guys see that lead Tim Ryan with 868
000 votes JD Vance 778 000 votes you
noted Jake that's with 37 of the
estimated vote uh is is fully in
82 percent of that vote is pre-election
vote it's early vote absentee by mail
vote early in-person vote where
Democrats tend to participate in in
bigger numbers than Republicans do at
the end of the day we think it's only
going to be 32 percent 32 percent of the
Ohio vote overall will be pre-election
vote so right now this this vote that
you're looking at is over inflated with
early votes not that they're not real
votes and they're counted it's just
making up such a larger share than we
think it will make at the end of the day
and that gives JD Vance and his campaign
hope that as more and more of that
election day vote comes in that
Republican leaning vote uh it's going to
help him potentially overtake uh Tim
Ryan in these vote totals all right
we'll keep watching the actual vote come
in uh and John can you take me down to
Georgia
as the Devil went down once what are we
looking at there
easiest ways to non-stop Delta flight
from DCA uh look you see again remember
this was not this close earlier right
yep and Not only was it not this close
earlier Senator Warnock was above 50
percent again we're still at 53 percent
uh if you were with us in uh 2020 for
the presidential race early 2021 for the
two Georgia runoffs uh these are
espresso races these are your up late
and you're probably counting the next
day as well but you are getting more of
the vote and you are seeing the margin
Titan so 49.6 to 48.7 19 000 vote lead
this is narrowed quite considerably and
again we were talking earlier the
Democratic incumbent Senator on top
right there when you look at the map
this is a state where you have a
democratic incumbent Senator and a
republican all right folks well as
expected it is getting tight
in the Georgia Senate and remember if no
one gets to 50 percent there's a runoff
so it is very very complicated we are
about to get more results at 9 00 pm
um
and just it's it's endless things going
on and I expect that that will be the
way it continues uh most of the night
quite frankly
Mike pillow called me out when I said
let's go machines on a live stream
mispronounced my name made my week
that's weird
can I get an answer on how Kenneth
Copeland can represent Trump and keep
his tax-exempt status
I have no idea shouldn't be able to
that's for sure
that's for damn sure
um
okay let's see yeah we're just moments
away I don't want to do too much because
we're about to get some important
results in one minute let me just get
caught up on thanking people mythadone
Wookie Jack and blooming basil really
appreciate the twitch Prime
subscriptions and also want to say thank
you to the three four
five people who just signed up on my
website folks today is the day to do it
we have a goal of 2000 we've never done
it before it is a I consider this the
beginning of what is going to be an
insane two-year period we have to
support strong independent media very
simply you can subscribe for free to my
YouTube channel this stuff costs nothing
look at these numbers going up there oh
wow look at that they're really
incredible now oh my goodness it's like
a slot machine in here look at that go
wow
I I'm liking it I'm liking it very much
it's great to have all of you here it's
great to be on all of these platforms
and by the way
everybody watching on on Facebook as
well let's listen 15 states with a slew
of high profile races and key
Battlegrounds including Arizona and we
have a CNN projection for you right now
in New York CNN is projecting that the
current Senate Majority Leader Democrat
Charles Schumer will be re-elected
defeating Joe pinion in South Dakota CNN
is projecting that a member of
Republican leadership Senator John thune
will be re-elected defeating Brian bangs
and in Kansas CNN is projecting that
incumbent Republican senator Jerry Moran
will be re-elected defeating Democrat
Mark Holland let's look at the map right
now and talk about the uh races that we
are not yet going to make a projection
they include the Senate races in Arizona
Colorado Iowa Louisiana North Dakota and
Wisconsin as of right now we do not have
a projection in those races the balance
of power of course 100 Senate seats
Democrats have 37 of those seats
Republican have 38 of those seats there
are 25 seats remaining Republicans only
need to pick up one net seat in order to
regain control of the U.S Senate there
are Governors races going on out there
as well let's go to Boris Sanchez for
that Jake two projections to bring you
right now beginning with a familiar face
being elected governor of Arkansas Sarah
Huckabee Sanders the former Donald Trump
press secretary slash communications
director following in the footsteps of
her father Mike Huckabee becoming the
new governor of Arkansas we should know
genuinely disgusting elected governor of
that state defeating Chris Jones another
projection to bring you now this one
from Rhode Island their incumbent
Democrat Dan McKee totally expected
First full term in the governor's
mansion remember he replaced Gina
raimondo when she left the governor's
mansion to join the Biden Administration
as the Commerce Secretary we have some
key rates alert key race alerts to bring
you now beginning with the state of
Texas last time we checked in former
Congressman Beto O'Rourke had a decent
Advantage it's over Craig Abbott the
incumbent Republican has overtaken him
nearly 170 thousand vote lead for Abbott
with 33 percent of the vote in an update
now from the peach state Georgia Brian
Kemp building on the lead that we saw
him take early it's over I'm I mean guys
I know it hasn't been called but Kemp's
gonna win it was very clear roughly
eight percent Advantage for kemp still
above that 50 threshold to avoid a
runoff with 55 percent of the vote in in
Georgia meantime an unexpectedly close
race in Oklahoma a key race alert there
Kevin Stitt the incumbent Kevin's tit is
taking over
a Democrat who actually flipped parties
just last year specifically for this
race stit right now 43 000 votes ahead
with 34 percent of the vote in Jake
Boris thanks so much uh let's the
balance of power in the U.S Senate 44
Democrats 40 Republicans so we don't yet
have projections from a whole bunch of
those places but the good news is they
are now in play and we're going to start
getting data from them so it has now
turned gray it's still zeros but we are
starting to get data actually Arizona
they might have said that even though
the polls closed the data will be
delayed an hour but in a lot of these
places we're going to start to get some
of that information let's check in on
some of the most important and critical
races that are going on this includes
starting now we are looking at
gubernatorial races gubernatorial races
okay
um actually oh here's an at a glance so
in Florida Ronda santis has one that was
expected it's not a surprise in Georgia
I'm not going to blow smoke anywhere for
you fine folks in Georgia the
expectation was Kemp would win he's
going to win he is now leading by eight
and I expect him to win by roughly eight
to ten it hasn't been called but it's
not looking good
um Maine is an interesting one we are
looking at uh Paul LePage running
against incumbent Mills LePage is ahead
with five percent of the vote
um Michigan is an extremely important
one where there was a Maga endorsed
clown named Tudor Dixon she is losing by
15. only 8 percent reporting only eight
percent reporting in Nevada
we don't yet have data looking at
Minnesota
we have the first numbers from New York
where Lee zeldin thankfully is losing
there's still a long time to go there a
long time to go there
Kevin's tit has taken a lead in Oklahoma
one of the most important races is
governor of Pennsylvania the good news
is that Josh Shapiro is up by 53 over
lunatic extremists Doug mastriano
literally a trump writer okay Texas I
expect Abbott to win and he's ahead
although there's people in the chat
saying David it's a red Mirage just wait
just wait we're waiting but I expect
Abbott to win in that particular one
that's Governors okay that's Governors
let's now go over to the Senate
let's go over to the Senate and look at
some of the most important races we have
no data yet from Arizona
in Florida it's already been called for
Rubio
arguably one of the most important races
alongside Pennsylvania is Warnock versus
Walker in Georgia with 61 percent
reporting they have Warnock plus 4.8 but
I believe that there's actually newer
data already
let me see where decision desk has this
one Georgia
is at 42 that's way behind
and
um New York Times
has it 52 with 82 okay uh
5247 with 50 actually so the newest
numbers are indeed these 61 percent
Warnock plus four uh it's shrinking a
little bit
um and I know that there are people
telling me that Walker is now ahead
these are the three panels I have and
these are showing
these are showing uh Warnock ahead for
the time being Grassley is arguably in a
tighter race than expected nothing's
been counted yet quite literally
nothing's been counted we don't have
anything out of Nevada yet Maggie Hassan
expected to win easily in New Hampshire
unfortunately in North Carolina Ted Budd
has now taken the lead
with 67 reporting
and then in Ohio Tim Ryan is very
narrowly holding a lead against JD Vance
but Vance expected to catch up expected
to catch up Pennsylvania a race of
absolutely critical importance fetterman
plus 45 only 11 reporting
okay and then nothing yet from Utah
Utah's interesting where independent
Evan McMullen is running former I think
former Republican that'll be a very very
interesting one and we are watching that
and then in the house for now it is
still three pickups three pickups for
Republicans remember Republicans are
expected to take the house there are so
many races and they're starting to fill
in we're getting starting to get data
from The Dakotas from Colorado and from
a lot of different places all
extraordinarily important in total in
total in total individually we we have
to just keep an eye on it I want to say
thanks to one two three four additional
people who just signed up on my website
putting us at
1569 new members and twitch subscribers
folks do not adjust your TVs do not
adjust your laptops do not adjust your
tablets uh that is that is real
1569 out of 2000 the goal is two
thousand we've been working on it for a
few days also thank you to zed France
and avionette for the twitch Prime
subscriptions if you have Amazon Prime
you get a free twitch Prime subscription
you're basically taking a few bucks from
Jeff Bezos and sending it to me
it's amazing that they allow you to do
that it really is let's listen as we
continue to monitor these results oh
hold on a second
let me get an update so we spoke to Ian
vosh people said why don't you talk to
Hassan Hassan is just ignoring me on
Discord Destiny let's see how long will
you be on that panel
we wanted to check in with Destiny he's
on a panel with Lauren Chen Blair white
and Sean they actually invited me Lauren
invited me to that panel
and um I said no because I'm doing this
folks do you understand that Lauren Chen
invited me to an exclusive panel of
dignitaries on Odyssey
and I said no I'm going to talk to you
guys instead
all right
um
let's see we'll see if Stephen can take
a little break
call Sam
all right let me text Sam let me see if
I can do that
Sam Cedar
want to connect to check in
Skype
Discord even better
let's see what Sam says that would be
interesting uh
that'd be super interesting all right
massive dump of twitch Subs thanks to
Trent coultson Gaijin sexatron Philly
troop and 2-7 that puts us at 1578 also
thank you to one additional person who
just signed up on my website that is
Stephen mcabee McCabe Stephen McCabe
thank you very much
really appreciate that
um destiny is banned on Twitch oh damn
oh you are banned on Twitch I just
realized so I guess
we can't
that's too bad well I'd love to check in
with Hassan if he was able to do it
but he seems to have bigger fish to fry
for lack of a better term uh Dan bites
Mike pillow called me out when I said
let's go machines on a live stream
mispronounced my name made my week
that's wild David thanks for the quality
coverage it's not going to be pretty can
I get an Obama yes hold on Obama
and we will ban men exactly
exactly exactly exactly uh let's I want
to listen to a couple of voicemails just
a couple a couple a couple of voicemails
yeah so I voted earlier this year
which was awesome and easy to do however
my friend went to the polls today and I
have no reason to disbelieve him
he said he put in a vote for a bit or
work
and when he went to review his sheet it
said that he put gray at it and he went
back and edited it and I feel like a
fool because I didn't review mine
so now I'm wondering if my boat got
messed I don't know this whole election
fraud thing has got us all confused
that's all I have to say thank you yeah
and your show's great thank you very
much yeah I know I mean listen I I don't
know I don't know these people everybody
starts getting worried that I do
something wrong what happened what
happened
um for the most part it's it's all like
fine it's all fine
a bay photo says unfortunate that the
likely best case scenario for Democrats
is keeping the Senate losing the house
and it means nothing will get passed for
at least two years sadly you were
correct but democracy is at stake let's
keep democracy but lose the house you
know I would rather that
sanjiman says supporting channel from
our safely blue District California 24.
sad news from other states side note EA
Sports predicts one last chance for
messy AFA to win the World Cup cheers
fellow argentinian-american San Giovanni
yeah folks I have my Argentina Men's
National Team Jersey ready to go I got
an Argentinian Men's National Team
onesie for my baby daughter
and I am ready for the World Cup
unfortunately it looks like some of
Argentina's games are at like 5 a.m East
Coast time
so that's not great
but I'm excited and I will probably be
wearing the Jersey on game days during
the World Cup
and also Qatar sucks yes Qatar sucks
indentured servitude used to build the
stadiums all of it all of it all of it
all of it not even a shadow of a doubt
thanks to Trigo crunchy robien better
IPA exargoon destructive eats Commander
Shep madman with a soapbox Mr first the
witty wombat Southpaw legendary Britain
kale SCI major gravy chain and advice
banana
putting us at 1593
super appreciate that let's get an
update
on the latest races the data is
approaching quickly we have new states
to look at
uh oh hold on did Sam text me back
no we did not people are saying go on
with Sam I'm trying to get a hold of Sam
um
is Sam on Discord I don't even know
doesn't seem to be
can I search for someone
Sam Cedar
Sam c yeah I don't know
we're gonna have to wait and see on that
let's see if Sam texts me back
if people want to tell Sam I'm texting
him that that's totally fine
uh
I don't even know that Sam's streaming I
mean I'm guessing he is all right let's
look at some numbers so we're starting
to see numbers come in from a bunch of
different states
uh Jared is it pronounced Jared paulus I
don't even know paulus I believe it's
paulus
um incumbent in Colorado very early
numbers 20 in paulus up by roughly two
to one that's good
um Kansas Kelly the incumbent is up
in Nebraska it's blood versus pillan
blood versus pillin
very very early
super important gubernatorial races
Pennsylvania
Shapiro plus 41 with only 15 percent of
the vote in
only 15 percent
uh New York
Kathy how is it pronounced hokel I never
understood how to pronounce it
is that the right pronunciation
nobody knows great
great super useful
uh
uh it's pronounced hokel okay Kathy
hokel fortunately up three to one over
Lee zeldon let's hope she puts him out
of his misery soon only nine percent of
the vote in
and then nothing yet out of Arizona
I believe I read we may not get data
from Arizona until uh 10 pm
but we will monitor that over in the
Senate
seats of critical import oh sorry hold
on I forgot Dixon versus Whitmer Whitmer
holding on to an eight-point lead but it
is tightening up now with 10 of the vote
that's not great you don't love to see
that all right over in the Senate
um in Pennsylvania with 15 of the vote
better of fetterman is up 31.
super early super super early some
people are saying it's gonna it's a Blue
Wave a blue Mirage others are saying
it's a red Mirage
we it's just sir it's just early guys we
just have to wait and then yes Warnock
still holding a lead over Herschel
Walker the vote count has slowed
dramatically dramatically dramatically
and it is a 4.2 percent lead and we are
anxiously waiting for the Arizona
numbers to start coming in as far as the
House of Representatives goes it is
still three pickups for Republicans
three pickups for republicans
and that is uh that is absolutely
critical absolutely critical to follow
I want to say thanks to Caleb Carr who
just signed up on my website
joinpakman.com
let's look at some super chats here
sending best wishes from Singapore if
the Dems can't keep the house in Senate
I just hope as little the election
deniers win as possible right as Feud
election deniers as possible I'm with
you
here's some money for you to get a fancy
coffee tomorrow much love David Dear God
dear God that is generous I appreciate
that
David served Republicans take the House
and Senate how strongly should they look
into Jew
I don't even know what that means what
does that mean
oh like when Kanye said I'm Jew that was
weird it was really weird
David loved the show letting you know
it's pronounced polis Jared Polis in
Colorado thank you I appreciate that
spread the news don't make your
daughters fight the war your
grandmother's already won
cheers from Miami long time viewer not
surprised about Florida results but I
also feel like I'm going insane hoping
for better results than we got tonight
yeah
oh okay
Josiah is a wonderful guy people
everywhere think so did you did you guys
know that
that's a super super interesting thing
uh okay let's see have we heard back
from Sam here
Sam
Sam seder please
no Sam
all right we're standing by for Sam I I
think we may be able to raise Sam but it
may just take a little bit thanks to
Pathos Porto's subu man polensky General
Anubis ziltoid trillville miera and not
that Dr Phil for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 1602 also
thanks to our great friend Lars Baron
Roth for gifting five subscriptions
putting us at 1607 massive dumps of
votes and memberships all of it and
thanks to the three kind folks who just
signed up on my website we are
anticipating the numbers so people
there's people confused Arizona closed
and yet we have no data from Arizona how
can this be my understanding is that
even though Arizona closed
20 minutes ago we aren't going to have
any data from Arizona until 10 pm
that's that's what has been repeated a
number of different times
David want to know if you consider
yourself a minimalist
um to some degree yeah to some degree I
do
I would say so
let's see what else we've got a lot of
people calling in
hey David this is Andrew from California
I was just listening to some Salem Radio
Network
I heard from them that Kerry Lake and
Blake Masters in the RNC in Arizona
file something to send voting television
because they're claiming there was some
issue with machines or something like
that based on some allegations as far as
I know it's alleged I don't know
because I wanted to know let's look at
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines
let's see they want to extend voting
uh yes that is something that's
happening
let's see what Forbes says a group of
Republican organizations filed emotion
they filed emotion to extend
voting hours in Maricopa County due to
voting machine issues Trump is talking
about it they want polls to stay open
until 10 mountain time which would be
midnight here
uh no word yet as to whether that's
something that they're going to be able
to accomplish the war is starting on the
machines that's clear
Marco Kane says I don't have a dog in
this fight but I hope fetterman gets
over to over the line he's gutsy and a
fighter Oz can go back to his show and
snake oil absolutely absolutely with you
let's in fact check in on what is
happening in Pennsylvania we are up to
16 of the vote counted paint pens guys
remember Pennsylvania it's is known for
painfully slow Counting
fetterman plus 26 right now
with 16 of the vote
fetterman's not going to win by 26. so
we know that Oz will close the gap the
question is by how much
by how much
um
in the house it is still just three
pickups for Republicans so far I would
love it for the people who in chat are
insisting that it's going poorly for
Democrats
which races have not gone as expected so
far I mean right everything is as
expected so far what do people mean it's
not going well for Democrats
like so so far I mean I'm not really
understanding it
nobody knows okay
interesting
thanks to montian for gifting 10
subscriptions via twitch also thanks to
Phil Eagles Al Johnson and Chris Pat
Jones
also thanks to deaf atheist for gifting
five
16 28 ladies and gentlemen
the goal is two thousand big thank you
to Mark Holt and Nathaniel crowning
shield for signing up on my website also
thanks to Diane bills burrow putting us
at 1631 folks this is a record we've
never had anything like this during a
stream ever ever ever I so appreciate
everybody who is here super chats
continue to come in
yeah I I keep getting the same Super
Chat uh it's very funny it's very funny
we're worried here in Wisconsin that
Michaels will be our next Governor
there's little that would be worse for
us I I'm with you in fact I did want to
look at Wisconsin a little bit
when it comes to
gubernatorial
with one percent of the vote Evers is
leading
can't really say much about that yet
and over in the a senate race
with four percent of the vote Mandela
Barnes is ahead by 40. again Mandela
Barnes is not going to win by 40. so we
know that that's going to close
we just have to see by how much and it
would be amazing for Mandela Barnes to
pull that out it would be genuinely
fantastic Raphael Warnock holding the
lead holding the lead JD Vance has taken
a lead in Ohio
he was pulling ahead
there was hope Tim Ryan could pull it
out JD Vance has taken a lead
that is an important race for sure
David is a coffee Aficionado what's your
favorite place to get coffee in Buenos
Aires I don't have a particular one
uh there's there's any honestly almost
any place is good for coffee
State Legislative races are trickling in
pretty slow now they are indeed
I know it's off subject that you catch
Walsh on Rogan yes uh we commented on it
today
David are you a fan of Broadway shows if
so what's your favorite I'm not a big
Broadway guy I'm really not
nah
David my wife won't stop talking about
you you're ruining my marriage my kids
are calling you Dad please stop
streaming all right good night everybody
no we are here and we are here very very
strongly and powerfully that's what's
going on right now
more voicemails coming in
okay so here's a run now so with
Christopher everyone was really happy
when he first got elected uh because
he's gonna legalize marijuana in
Illinois and he did really glass
marijuana so that happened so it's a big
accomplishment of his and then also his
big accomplishment is is um that I
remember is uh Illinois was a junk
credit rating and now it's uh it's a lot
better maybe it's a c or something like
that well that caller is shot out of a
cannon that is really something else
hey it's Mark from Chicago uh I'm not
talking about Illinois today it looks
like we got things pretty much wrapped
up looking at Wisconsin Ron Johnson that
debate answer where he said
you know just those horrible things
about his opponent when he was asked to
say something nice yeah that's the least
Wisconsin thing I've ever heard it was
crazy you know like in the Bears if this
doesn't happen if he loses I think it's
because of that uh stay safe out there
let's hope so
let's hope so it would be amazing
um fetterman's still leading only 17
percent of the vote leading by 23 and a
half
it's it's tightening folks it's
tightening
at the top of the hour we are going to
get a huge dump of poll results and we
should start getting the Arizona
information oh let's see if I heard from
Sam here
Sam
all right we may be able to check in
with with Sam
that would be really great
see here
I can get that going
all right not quite yet thanks to failed
States for gifting five subscriptions
via twitch also thanks to skin flute
sacred H gray and Timmy eats Pizza
putting us at
1640. lastly Thanks To Grim cheaper
tummy take
S2 eki
very much appreciate that and a huge
thank you to David Wilson Nicholas
Mercado and Gordon Hall for the
subscriptions on my website folks if you
want a free membership to the David
Pacman show just fill out your name and
email at davidpackman.com free
membership we are giving them out and
there are many many to give away
uh a simple thank you for streaming this
says Rob well thank you it's great to be
here Rob
Shapiro's still up by 32 that's good
he likely won't win by 32.
okay
so that's that
judge denies motion by Republicans to
extend polling in Maricopa County
seems like the correct decision
sir have you looked into New Hampshire
congressional district one Pappas versus
Levitt I have not I wouldn't be able to
comment on that specific race
David sir we're screwed either way are
we screwed either way because even if
Dems win it will be January 6th all over
again but even worse but even worse I am
worried about that I am very much
worried about that no doubt about it
no doubt about it
uh but listen all we can do is use our
votes
right I mean what else can we do of
course those are concerns
of course those are concerns let's
listen to a little bit of an analysis of
Shapiro mastriano critical race twin
County uh Donald Trump won it just
barely in 2016 when he won the
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania Joe Biden
flipped it won it just barely in 2020
when he won so it is never like that
even if Josh Shapiro wins it big it is
never like that it just doesn't happen
so that tells you you're looking at
early votes and we have a long way to go
uh so where else you look here you
obviously you come down to Philadelphia
to see what votes in here only 34 only
13 percent of the vote in you see Josh
Shapiro at 94 the Democrat most likely
will be overwhelmingly up when we get to
Philadelphia's final count but not that
uh if he's up by that much then we have
a blowout on our hands if he is up by
that much and so then you walk out from
here and again you come to Bucks County
uh this is the the more competitive of
the caller Suburban counties it still
was a Joe Biden by four points in 2020
yeah again you know that would be
shocking uh but you'd rather be ahead
than behind but again you're looking
disproportionately at early votes and so
this is the governor's right let's just
come out and look at it again you know
whether it's early or late in the count
you want to start ahead there's the
governor's race Josh Shapiro at 64.4
percent right the Republic 123 000 yeah
the Republican candidate for governor
just look at some interesting house
races if we can including in Colorado
which district is bobair
forget is she the third yes early vote
37 of the vote is in Colorado's Third
District Lauren bobert currently down by
3.9
I don't know enough about that District
to know whether I believe it's Adam
Frisch really has a shot
but it would be amazing to defeat Beau
bear
um
kirkmeyer versus caraveo
going pretty heavily towards Kirk Meyer
there all Races which we will be
covering remember what matters is how
many seats do Republicans pick up they
are expected to take control of the
House of Representatives they have
currently picked up three seats
currently you've picked up three seats
uh
okay
have you heard the judge at Wayne Wright
Dental Elementary in Houston refusing to
sign ballots insisting everyone leave
when polls close no I did not see that
that sounds bonkers
I recall it Jesse Lee Peterson data clip
on the sound board seems appropriate can
I get data on the next major update I
don't have that on my current soundboard
iteration long story why but
too long of a story for today
um okay that one we dealt with
Matthew says can you thank my wife
Allison for her hard work and vote today
in New York thank you for all you do
David yes thank you Allison very much
appreciate your hard work
candidate party vote okay we can't
that's that's just that's a ton of just
numbers
sir the great state of Maryland just
went blue after eight years with Larry
Hogan everyone come over over four crab
cakes okay let's look at that Maryland
uh so I mean it hasn't been called as
far as what I'm seeing but it is very
very very heavily slanted in the
direction of the Democrat that is
absolutely true and a welcome result
from the standpoint of water how wet is
Elon musk's Perpetual whining and
hypocrisy his fragile ego erratic
business management and fandom sucks
well said
I want the Republicans to win if there's
a chance the flow of weapons to Ukraine
will stop I'm from there fighting for
Crimea or donbass is not worth it all
right well thank you for your input
thanks to Patricia Johnston Matthew [ __ ]
and Reuben Miranda all of whom just
signed up on my website putting us at
16.50 folks we can do it we can do it
thanks to drunk debate Segway cop and
chocolate bacon crunch putting us at
16.53
uh voicemails continuing to come in
here's Juan
hey David it's Juan here watching stream
so I was having a
a nice chat you know in the Stream there
and uh
I basically said that I wrote a 99 98
Republican in Florida and I've ordered
Democrat for Senate and House Kennedy
and someone in the chat says
why why even bother and well the point
is
you know uh it's not all or nothing you
vote
for the candidates
that will hopefully address your
concerns
uh all right well listen Juan has a
whole thing going on down there a whole
thing going on down there uh people
wanting to check in on how Fox News is
doing let's do it I am curious how
they're covering this let's take a
listen I think this is Laura Ingram
although she looks a lot different
somehow I don't know what but let's
let's listen [ __ ] right now but again
there's it's a long night ahead it is
and it's great to have you here joining
us is now is Republican National
committee chair Ronald McDaniel uh
thanks so much for being here your
initial impressions of of tonight oh
it's great
well I think it's going to be a long
night I think your analysis has been
spot on but I do think looking at
Florida where we were four years ago was
in recount territory for Rick Scott and
Ron DeSantis both of them within one
percent and to see what we have seen
tonight really is a seismic shift and I
think a lot of that's going to come from
the Hispanic population the rnc's had
community centers and Miami-Dade for
over a year we've really engaged with
this I mean a little less what we would
expect here from Fox News and then we
also have MSNBC the problem we've been
having with the MSNBC feed is this
blinking this blinking is just
absolutely terrible and I don't even
know what I can do about it
um
I've refreshed and it just doesn't fix
it it's it's horrifying but let's listen
a little bit held seats here so take a
look like at Virginia seven we told you
the story a minute ago we're still
waiting on the absentee vote from two
heavily Democratic areas in this
District an opportunity still for
spanberger who's trailing by 5 400 votes
to catch yesley Vega and to save this
seat for Democrats you take a look at
Pennsylvania seven Susan Wilde again
it's early it's heavily male that's when
they need to hold on to here's one the
Democrats are very excited about right
now Rhode Island too now this was a
heavily Biden District but Alan Fung the
Republican candidate here got a lot of
national attention uh this thing was
seen as a pure toss-up race heading into
today and we're getting up to 90 percent
of the vote and actually what we've seen
Happening Here is mail vote coming in
vote by mail coming in and pushing Seth
magazine or into the lead in this
District so again I think I have a
solution which is to pull up MSNBC in a
different browser her and I think we
fixed it let's listen
oh hold on let me unmute
but this could is this high enough for
Democrats to withstand the same day and
win it's certainly possible right now
you're not looking at this district and
saying oh yeah I could see Republicans
are definitely on their way to winning
there Henry Cuellar in Texas's 28th
District probably the most conservative
Democrat in the house survived a primary
Challenge from the left running in this
region of Deep South Texas that we saw
go it's Trend heavily towards the
Republicans in 2020 now it's some some
of cuer's best areas of the district are
reporting so far but with half the vote
he's sitting near 60 percent right there
again I'm just what I'm showing you is
outside of those sort of gimme seats in
Florida and plus one in Tennessee and
one in Georgia I'm not showing you seats
we're at this moment Republicans are
clearly poised to get flips that's not
to say they're not going to be
interesting flips in those in those
seats that I just showed you
um meanwhile and they did pick up a two
new seats but what I wanted to show you
was Democrats themselves have some tar
have some seats that they here we go
Democrats ourselves have some seats that
they could flip that's this page right
here so take a look like at Michigan
three this is where in the Republican
primary Peterman so listen all the
people putting in the chat
it's a disaster for Democrats so far
I'm just not oh I've interviewed this
guy John Gibbs he's out of his mind it's
not looking terrible right now for
Democrats given what was expected on the
way in
David says hey David can you thank my
fiance Aaron for her support she's a
huge fan of yours absolutely Aaron thank
you for your support I really appreciate
that very very much so all right let's
uh oh we've got a projection Democratic
senator Michael Bennett has been
re-elected in the next Colorado Senate
race this was a highly a tightly watched
race because the Republicans are very
confident in their candidate there Joe
O'Day but Joe O'Day comes up short
Michael Bennett will be returning to the
Senate back to you Steve yeah so and
that that by the way that Colorado quote
that's I mean listen
it wasn't close but you always want to
be sure that you get those you always
want to be sure that you get those
um okay let's reset it is the day of the
2022 midterms in the United States of
America democracy is essentially on the
ballot here one party listen folks this
isn't about
who wants a 37 tax rate versus who wants
39.
it's not about that okay this is
fundamentally about
do we believe
that when a candidate gets more votes
they should assume the office they ran
for
it's crazy that that's what this is
about but that's essentially where we
are in this country right now it's also
about is there any bar too low for a
republican candidate
Kerry Lake
absolutely no you know standards in the
toilet
Herschel Walker
Mehmet Oz
Doug mastriano
JD Vance
is there any candidate where
Republicans are willing to say hey you
know what even though I don't like
Democrats
this is too low
this is too low even for us
I don't know
I don't know at this point in time uh
and maybe maybe we will be able to
answer that question today
um
okay we're gonna ban some people
just toxic horrible horrible people
uh
uh and let's let's continue on
they got to stop baiting us calling
these safe races as if they were ever in
question yeah I know it gets confusing
that's confusing in 20 minutes
we are getting a huge dump of vote
numbers let's just check I just want to
check whether
there is any no this is not it
do we have any data from Arizona no
nothing from Arizona yet
latest numbers in Pennsylvania Shapiro
still up big
and then over in the Senate
fetterman's still up but it's tightening
it is certainly tightening and then in
Georgia
Warnock up by 1.4 Dear God
if the race ended like this it would go
to a runoff
in Georgia which is very dangerous it
would be better for Warnock to win out
well let's back up
it would be better for Warnock to win
it would be better if he's going to win
to win with at least 50 percent to avoid
a runoff
because a runoff could get very
dangerous very dangerous imagine a
situation
where this goes to a runoff and
determines who controls the Senate and
Republicans pour every last dollar into
this race to make Herschel Walker who
can't even speak
certainly can't think
one of 100 senators from the United
States scary stuff
very very scary stuff
um Kevin's tit has been re-elected not a
big shock
thank you for your optimism David from
mid Michigan listen it's not about
optimism or pessimism it's about realism
just where are we right now how are
things looking right now
uh and that's that's essentially Where
We Are
I do want to say thank you to Amber
Fritz Kevin way and Sean Irwin for
signing up on my website joinpakman.com
uh we are just at the beginning this is
just the beginning folks we first have
to figure out who's winning today
later we go to how does this impact the
next two years
and how does it impact 2024
what I can assure you
is that this is going to be a crazy two
years I see people in chat asking am I
worried about censorship from Maga
between Republicans probably taking
control of the house and maybe the
Senate
and uh Elon Musk buying Twitter and all
these different things yeah listen I
mean we we worry about everything
we worry about everything
but uh we do what we can at the time and
so I will uh mention
that
we in left-wing media have been talking
amongst ourselves how are we going to
deal with
certain aspects of this if indeed
Republicans take control but we're
waiting on that
Dino says via Super Chat David senior
the amount of members you have tonight
is suspicious is the member count
tabulated by a machine perhaps you
ordered your henchmen to dump fake
memberships in no
I know people are saying David usually
you go for like a hundred memberships 2
000 how do you have 16 53
it's an incredible day that is a
cumulative number over the last four
streams but we are shooting for two
thousand let me tell you right now
the best thing you can do go to my
website folks go to my website
joinpakman.com you will get instant
access to the bonus show hard to beat
that Pac-Man's a loser oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad this is not a joke Alex Jones
hates my membership program he hates it
he's out there owing people 900 million
and meanwhile we've got 600 new members
okay
joinpakman.com monthly or yearly I don't
care do whichever one you want hit the
sign up button okay coupon code above my
head
hey you know what
should we just launch the new coupon
code right now
like what am I even really waiting for
folks let's do it the new coupon code
is just the truth the code is 24.
Starts Now
20 look at this folks
this is Criminal
Criminal
Attorneys General are frothing to come
after me this is the code first person
to use it on my website
gets a free item from my online store
whatever you want I'll send you the Hat
I'll send you the mug I'll send you the
Band-Aids just kidding there's no
Band-Aids all right back to the results
but in all seriousness that is the new
code
let's make it a reality
let's make it an incredible reality all
right super chat's continuing to come in
David if the house or centered or lost
tonight what should Biden's strategy be
for getting stuff done
uh put Republicans in the position of
being obviously insane for blocking the
things you want to do now that means you
can't get very ambitious things done
that's a reality
let's let the dust settle and talk about
that tomorrow
I'm worried my rights as a gay man can
be taken away and trans rights taken
away if Republicans win more seats like
I pray to Jesus that if they do win that
we lgbtq don't lose rights thanks David
many folks in the LGBT community are
extraordinarily concerned about that
Shanti says two gay guys in Alabama
looking to move Colorado Washington
State or Oregon I've never been to
Washington State or Oregon so I would
not be the right person to advise on
that
I don't want to lead you astray that's
for sure
where are we here there we go
hey from Kiev Ukraine Kiev Ukraine we
are fighting for our lives and freedom
against Russian fascism and genocide
very disappointing to hear you thank yon
for his disgusting comment
I I was thanking Jan sarcastically it
very very clearly sarcastically I
apologize if that didn't come through
very much so
uh welcome to Alexander Hamilton and
Cobra via twitch Prime
folks we are seeing a dump of
memberships on the website like we have
never seen before I want to say thanks
to Jeff Gilliland
but most importantly the first oh no
Barrett Meeker didn't use the code
either we're still waiting for the first
person to use the new code 24 starts now
actually let me put it up here 24 starts
now
first person to use the code 24 starts
now gets the free item of their choice
from the online store there's 53 people
trying to do it right now David never
mind George Soros
is your channel single-handedly funded
by user user s press exactly Espress has
dumped 2 900 memberships on us uh okay
we are standing by
12 minutes from now
we may get our first Arizona data
s Perez has just gifted a hundred more
subscriptions putting us at
17.57 couch bunnies makes it 1758.
incredible
David sir seeing as you have presumably
visited Colorado what was your
experience like support from Denver well
I visited Denver that's the only place
I've been in the state of Colorado and I
had a nice time I didn't see that much I
was there for a conference but it was
it it was a nice city it seemed like
quality of life was quite High
I wish I could you know I'd like to
spend more time there for sure
Mike pillow said he would be live
streaming tonight with his cyber guys
where they would be watching it get
stolen live is he streaming that's a
good question uh what's the website
frankspeach.com or something like that
access denied
weird
seems like they're having a website
outage
now I don't know what happened with it
quite frankly
it's pretty crazy
yeah it's weird Frank's Frank's speech
was supposed to be streaming
we'll have to wait and see
um David Sir with tears in my eyes I
think you have the best live stream
people don't know it but it's the best
in the history of the country I I
appreciate that I really do
Panera Bread ad just popped up thoughts
on that chain I've never been inside of
one I do not recommend going to Panera
do not go to Panera uh do I I would not
go to Panera
um
Arizona State Legislative results are
tied house 10 to 10 Senate four to four
more to come
now I wonder
some interesting folks here
okay oh thank you to soft porn that's
p-o-u-r like to pour coffee who just
subscribed via twitch I follow soft porn
p-o-u-r-n on Tick Tock does really great
coffee content highly recommend
do you think the GOP win control of the
house if they win they will really cut
Social Security I don't think so I think
they know that it is absolute and total
political suicide
tell me if tell me if you think I'm
wrong but I think they know it is
absolute political suicide let's listen
Bata polls close
friend Jacob sober
us right now in Henderson Nevada with
only about 10 minutes on the clock Jacob
it looks like there's still a ton of
people there
yeah maybe as many Rachel as three 400 I
was just talking to the election
officials way at the front of the line
when I talked to you guys last about
three hours ago there was only one line
uh right here and it ended all the way
up by the Christmas tree now now it kind
of doubles back three times almost like
an amusement park and let me just show
you what's going on here the line
actually still snakes uh almost I think
hold on one second let me just run and
check I think all the way outside
yeah so there are so there are people
outside uh right now Rachel that are
waiting in this line and I think you
know what's important to note for people
who are watching us right now people who
might still be in this line if you are
in this line
within the next 10 minutes you are going
to get to vote even if you're outside
that's right small actually closes uh at
10 o'clock Eastern seven o'clock local
time uh but they want everybody to vote
so when I talked to you last I think the
total was just over 2 000 the tally as
of right now is almost 2500 people have
voted at this location and I have I've
been monitoring what John Ralston the
dean of the Nevada press Corps has been
saying about turnout here that uh
overall it appears to him to be lower
than he expected it to be that hasn't
been the case here it also has not been
all right folks I am being notified that
the our website is under such heavy load
from people trying to sign up
you guys may have crashed the website uh
I am going to have it all taken care of
right now this is crazy
so many people are trying to sign up
right now on the website
that the website is down it's it is
unbelievable for some people it's slow
three people were able to do it okay let
me do this
um Richard walquist is the first person
to successfully sign up with the new
coupon code 24 starts now
you can email info davidpackman.com to
get your
um free item
I am going to restart the server right
now so many of you Maniacs are trying to
use this new code that you crash the
website it is stunning
stunning I guess this is a good problem
to have
people saying the code is not working
the code is working
the website is just collapsing under the
pressure of all of you people we're
going to continue on we have results in
eight minutes let's get through a few
other super chats here Frank's speech
site is up and I'm watching the live
stream oh
um I somehow banned from Frank's speech
let's see
it's possible could he possibly have
banned me no it's going to some weird
WordPress thing I I think
yeah I don't know
it's very strange
um hello from Kansas City Missouri I
know our state Senate and House races
might be a red blowout but we're hoping
recreational marijuana passes any
thoughts also get barbecue sometime yeah
I've been to Kansas City Missouri I
think I went to
uh KCMO BBQ places let me see if I can
remember which one I went to I went to
Arthur Bryant's
Arthur Bryants Christie gnome won South
Dakota no surprise that is exactly what
was expected
that is exactly what was expected
um
couple other voicemails coming in
hello uh from Denver I know you're going
to get to it sooner or later but I just
have to try and point out to you that
you need to look at the bobert results
we will the New York Times has her down
18 points at this point I never expected
it takes
yep
it let's actually I think we have time
to look at it
before
we get to let's see here bobert
okay so we go to Colorado
um God which one of these is it Third
District with 45 reporting Adam Frisch
is leading Lauren bobert by 5.7
it would be
unbelievable if Lauren bobert could be
knocked off that would be amazing that
would be amazing
um
but we just have to wait and see we just
have to wait and see let's get updates
from
uh Wisconsin
30 reporting Evers ahead of Michael's
that's good news in Michigan with 14
reporting Whitmer is ahead of Tudor
Dixon but not by that much
and in Pennsylvania critical race
Shapiro ahead by 21 with 36 percent of
the vote in sticking with Pennsylvania
the latest Senate data with 36 percent
reporting is fetterman Plus 11.
it's continuing to tighten it's
continuing to tighten
uh okay let's get back over to let's
take a listen here Beasley's number is
actually a little bit underneath bidens
but Bud's number is underneath Trump is
underneath Trump's number two so Bud's
not getting quite what he was expecting
out of here now take a look like here's
a core democratic County Orange County
this is where Chapel Hill is Democrats
are going to get a big number but
Beasley is getting two folks the website
is back up
tons of people are signing up let's hope
it stays up the new code 24 starts now
is firing up a lot of people there's 232
people trying to sign up right now I
don't even know if the website is
designed for that quite frankly I just
don't know
um
but it's up right now
it's up right now and
that I can tell you that I can tell you
thanks to saroja smona bling bling the
bunny diboxide
as well as smooth brain ape living
vertex has gifted five that puts us at
1769. ladies and gentlemen we've never
seen anything like it one two three four
five
six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen folks using that new coupon
code putting us at 1782 we can't even
keep up with it as we are almost at the
stroke of 10. uh oh
so let's see is Hassan joining us it
doesn't look like it
and is Sam Cedar joining us it does not
seem like it okay
um
all right let's listen here or no a
couple other oh oh my God look at this
Herschel Walker the most unqualified man
in the world has taken a lead in the
Georgia Senate race Herschel Walker may
be the next senator from Georgia
which would humiliate us as a global
joke
but remember if nobody gets 50 there's a
runoff
if nobody gets fifty percent there's a
runoff
what if David from 15 years ago could
Envision this moment describing a party
that will assume fraud in any case they
lose and that their followers will buy
it this isn't normal it is not normal
Charlie
you were absolutely correct
do you think pollsters can reach gen Z
voters I don't know and I have a segment
on the show today about this
very very powerful segment on today's
show
um I I don't I don't know there are
definitely issues with Poland definitely
issue with Poland we are uh two minutes
from huge vote dumps okay so everybody
stand by here really important we're I
believe going to get our first Arizona
data let's listen neither candidate gets
that does not get to 50 I do have a
couple I do have at least one call to
make uh in the Louisiana U.S Senate race
NBC News can now project that incumbent
Republican senator John Kennedy has been
re-elected his Democratic opponent was
Gary Chambers but John Kennedy will be
returning to the United States Senate at
this hour the Democrats control 40 seats
in the Senate the Republicans control 41
they're still 19 seats to go we do have
two minor changes in characterization
both in the same direction in the New
York governor's race this race is still
considered too early to call but I can
tell you that NBC now describes this as
one a race in which Kathy hokel is in
the lead okay
but incumbent Democrat Kathy hokel in
the lead similarly in the main
governor's race the Democratic incumbent
there is Janet Mills it is too early to
call between her and her Republican
Challenger the former governor of Maine
Paul LePage it is too early to call but
NBC news's election desk now
characterizes Democratic incumbent Janet
Mills as being in the lead so again in
the New York governor's race and in the
main governor's race we've got
Democratic incumbents there both in the
lead although they're both too early to
call
it's fascinating I mean the thing that I
think is the clearest is you know just
I'm gonna do what Lawrence was doing and
I'm just gonna repeat Christine a couple
lines is that they're trying to get the
Brian Tyler Cohen to join us he's never
we've never done anything together but
we recently exchanged some messages
um I'm gonna see if we can get him
because he's also live streaming and
that would be a really really great
thing okay so standby if you're watching
him or whatever uh you can tell him I'm
trying to get a hold of him via Twitter
DM that's how we communicate so that
that would be cool if we can get him on
thanks to this Juan for gifting five
subscriptions via twitch we are uh
oh actually let's just listen because
these polls are closing within seconds
we don't want to miss it here we go they
were for list trusses policies which
ended her prime
primary is coming said Stephen Moore so
I think the fact that they ran on crime
and they ran on inflation and they
didn't have any solutions voters sought
through some of that 10 o'clock
in about 15 seconds here on the East
Coast the poll closings at 10 o'clock
are Montana and Nevada and Utah again
we're still watching all of the closed
Senate races in the country right now
but with polls closing right now in
those three states uh this is what we
can tell you in terms of the NBC News
election desk and projections at this
hour in the Nevada Senate race
incumbent Catherine Cortez masto facing
a republican Challenge from Adam laxalt
this race is currently not characterized
on our screen but I believe this is too
early to call correct yes in the Utah
Senate race incumbent Republican Mike
Lee facing an independent Challenge from
Evan McMullen this is also too early to
call in the Nevada governor's race
we're looking at a democratic incumbent
Steve sisilak who's facing a republican
Challenge from Joe Lombardo this is all
two also too early to call again so too
early in Nevada Senate Utah Senate and
Nevada Governors let's recap what's
going on in some of these closely
watched Senate races the North Carolina
Senate race it is too close to call
between Republican Ted Budd and Democrat
Sherry Beasley in the Georgia Senate
race it is too early to call between
Democratic incumbent Raphael Warnock and
Republican Herschel Walker look how
tight they are in the Ohio Senate race
it is too early to call between
Republican J.D Vance and Democrat Tim
Ryan that's about two-thirds of the vote
in in the Pennsylvania Senate race with
about 40 percent of the vote in it is
too early to call between Democrat John
Federman and Republican Mehmet Oz in the
New Hampshire
interesting Senate race here it is too
early to call Maggie Hassan the
Democratic incumbent facing Republican I
think that's going to be callable soon
less than 40 percent of the vote in it
is too early to call in New Hampshire
and in Arizona we are looking at a too
early to call race between Mark Kelly
the Democratic incumbent and the
Republican Challenger Blake Masters
at this hour the Democrats control 40
Senate seats the Republicans control 41
19 are still in play Steve I'm working
on getting Brian on it looks like we're
going to be able to make it happen
individual house races that you're
watching if you got more new news for us
on that front yeah why don't we start in
Ohio because we talked about Ohio's
important a couple different districts
here for different reasons so you can
see the senate race here right now with
Vance about two-thirds in ahead of Ryan
I was just looking at some of the
counties where we have all of the vote
in and what the pattern that I'm finding
so far is the advance seems to be
running underneath Donald Trump's number
but not underneath it necessarily to the
degree he would need to for Ryan to win
outright there are still some big
Democratic areas with a lot of vote but
there are some encouraging counties for
Vance remember Trump won this state by
eight points but when you take a look at
the house races the key house races in
Ohio let's start up here at Marcy
captors district and again this is one
of those Trump voting
Democratic held districts it's in that
first line of attack for Republicans
right this District was drawn in a way
where Republicans looked at and said
we're going to pick this up Marcy kept
their 40-year Democrat veteran
two-thirds of the vote in here now let's
dive a little deeper and show you these
are the component counties of the
district and you see captors leading and
we know that what's being counted right
now is primarily same-day vote which is
generally the most Republican friendly
vote so you'd say Okay chance for
Majewski here here's the problem for
Majewski let me take you in a quick tour
of the district here look how much vote
is in in the core Republican counties
they're already up to 90 percent in
Defiance County basically 90 percent in
Williams over 93 percent in Fulton you
look over here in Sandusky County
they're over 90 percent
Ottawa County which is very competitive
you know they're basically now look
where there's still outstanding vote the
motherload Lucas County okay this is
where Toledo is now it's same-day vote
that is good news if that holds that is
very good news because it was looking
like Majewski might take this one it's
it's 45 let's hope in this district is
coming from a core democratic area and
captor already leads in the district so
if you're a Democrat I think you're all
right folks we're going to be linking up
with Brian Tyler Cohen momentarily this
is a this is a critical moment first
congressional district and this one's
getting close and this one's going to be
very very important
[Music]
oh boy that didn't work
we're gonna get it going there are still
votes to come same day votes you expect
that to be heavily Republican here we go
hey Brian
oh you've got video oh hold on let's see
if we that's even better I can bring you
on with video let's see here let's see
if we can bring Brian on folks look at
this
can you hear me Brian I can oh wow
you're are we live right now uh well I'm
off my screen right now oh you're off
okay you and I are live on my channel
okay great long time coming am I this is
an incredible moment I have to tell you
yeah uh it is so great to have you on
and history is being made I I finally I
blinked first I have to say I believe
that me not having a middle name as part
of my branding
has probably cost me 300 000 YouTube
subscriptions if I was like David Tyler
packman I feel like I would be killing
right now I'll tell you what uh not not
great these days be named after
cryptocurrency uh I hope that my stock
is higher than cryptocurrency stock is
right now
um but alas here we are actually the
reason why I have a middle name is
because I used to act and there were way
too many Brian Tyler Cohen's I think it
was like the 16th so I was forced to to
dig deep to bring my last name into the
picture I think that that makes a lot of
sense so uh so what are you thinking
right now how's everything looking from
your end you know there's a bunch of
people in my chat who are saying it's
looking terribly for Democrats but
compared to what it looked like four
days ago it's sort of looking like maybe
it's okay
I I feel cautiously optimistic about
this and here's why there were a bunch
of potential pickup opportunities for
Republicans the Democrats have already
been able to Stave off Michael Bennett
out in uh in Colorado Seth magazina in
Rhode Island's second congressional
district Jennifer waxston in Virginia's
10th congressional district we have
Virginia's seventh congressional
district as well that looks to be a hold
with Abigail spanberger so these were
these were like break glass scenarios
for uh for Democrats and it's not
looking like we're succumbing to any of
those uh to to those like you know
disastrous situations
um from the right right now I agree so
you know we're going to keep an eye on a
lot of this stuff but uh even even uh
Herschel Walker and Rafael warnock's
race is looking pretty good for
Democrats right now so the last update I
got on that race all of a sudden does
does not look quite so good I don't know
what source you're using because if you
look at if you look at where the votes
are still outstanding if you look at
Columbus we still have 40 of the votes
outstanding if you look at Augusta which
is another major Democratic population
Center we're looking at 15 percent of
votes still outstanding that's
enrichment and then all the Atlanta
suburbs were waiting on in Fulton County
30 of the vote still in um in DeKalb
County 30 of the vote still in Gwinnett
County half the votes still have to come
in and in Cobb County about 35 percent
of the vote so there's still a lot of a
lot of votes left to to be you know to
be got by uh by uh Rafael Warnock that
is absolutely true and that must be 10
minutes old data because some of those
numbers are lower than you just
mentioned and my concern is that the
early lead seems heavily skewed like the
so the latest update now up to 78
percent has pushed Walker into the lead
so listen I hope you're right absolutely
I'm I'm getting a little bit worried
about it yeah I mean look we wouldn't be
Democrats if we weren't a little bit
worried exactly
um all right well I'm going to jump back
over to my channel let's do this again
in a few minutes if that's okay with you
yeah yeah just let me whenever you're
ready I'll just leave my Skype on
excellent thanks talk to you guys soon
Brian Tyler Cohen uh an historic moment
ladies and gentlemen in the uh in the in
David Pacman show I have to tell you so
we'll leave that on
and then uh
this is sort of going okay I think right
guys I mean I don't know
um okay good Hogan says David Sir with
tears in my eyes can I get a shout out
from my pregnant wife shout out to your
pregnant wife also can my unborn child
use the coupon code yes
I don't want to add more prison time to
your illegal coupon code no concern
whatsoever
no concern whatsoever folks s Prez just
gifted another 100 subscriptions putting
us at 1887.
okay
um
this Juan gifted another five sounded
great in Howling Stars have signed up
and then beef no beef stews we already
got on my website ladies and gentlemen I
don't even know let me see this hold on
new membership I want to get the right
number 42.
6 that's 36. ladies and gentlemen we are
on the precipice of David Pacman's show
history we may hit 2 000 new members and
twitch subscribers at the moment that
Brian Tyler Cohen joins us back which
would just be unbelievable it would just
be unbelievable it none of this has ever
happened before and hopefully Herschel
Walker will lose his race all all things
happening at the same time which would
be unbelievable welcome to geostigma
gifting 5 as well as Toby is six is 1942
and ladies and gentlemen we have done it
s press gifting another 100
subscriptions as well as Melody putting
us over two thousand let's go for twenty
five hundred I am not afraid if you're
not afraid
that I can tell you right now
I'll go for it David sir will you send
best wishes to my brother in Arkansas
where Sarah Huckabee Sanders is now
Governor yeah
you're gonna need it
you're gonna need it best wishes for
sure
uh that is that is brutal brutal brutal
brutal stuff
I would not want to be living in
Arkansas right now that's for damn sure
that is for damn sure let's take a look
at the updated bobair numbers which I
know a lot of people are worried about
69 of the vote in and Lauren bobert is
down 4.3
that is tightening up
but folks we might kick out Beau bear
listen I I have to tell you
if we zoom out a little bit okay the
three main trumpian clowns of the House
of Representatives are bobert green and
cawthorne
cawthorne lost his primary
green is easily winning
bobert might lose that would be getting
rid of two out of three now
we are starting to get data from Arizona
and I really want to look at that data
very very closely
let's start looking at the gubernatorial
data with 40 of the vote in
Hobbes is ahead of Kerry Lake by 11
folks this is like when a pitcher is
pitching a perfect game
I don't want to say too much
we're going to watch that really closely
this is one of the critical
Bellwether of it's like an insane
bellwether
has the country descended into full
psychosis
this race will tell us a lot of that
okay this race will tell us a lot of
that
um
and then over in the Senate
we have our first data in Kelly versus
Masters another critical race with 41
reporting Mark Kelly is up 15.
over representing early voting
over-representing Malin
these are these are
Bellwether races
Bellwether races
we are going to watch both
very closely
we are going to watch them very very
closely
um let's see what's going on I don't
know what's going on with Brian
all right
sir you might ask BTC how he secured
high-profile interviews with Biden also
tdps show membership clearly won the
midterms yeah the real winner is right
here see this number right here that's
the real winner here
it was great to see you in BTC in one
show enjoy both of you yeah hopefully
he'll he'll call back soon keep us in
your thoughts here in Oklahoma David sad
day very sad you you guys are in our
thoughts extremely sad situation there
let's hear the analysis on Kelly Masters
Democratic County but uh that Pima piece
of it that'll come in in a minute uh
will be significant can I ask our study
cam operator if I could see that shot of
Steve's papers again
[Laughter]
organized over here okay you were
looking down Rachel the most magical
part of the moment was that he found
when he was looking forward
I couldn't find what I'm looking for in
front of me if we don't do the slow
motion replay someone is going to do it
online
I have some characterizations I need to
make here I'm sorry to interrupt
especially given what we were talking
about in the Illinois Senate race NBC
News can now project that in the
Illinois Senator okay thank goodness
Tammy Duckworth is reelected Tammy
Duckworth will be returning to the
United States Senate in the Georgia
Senate race this was previously
characterized as too early to call this
is now two oh my goodness look at that
between Raphael Warnock and Herschel
Walker look at those numbers 49 with
less than less than 700 votes between
them how do you call that too close to
call that's with just under 80 percent
of the vote it is too close to call in
the Georgia Senate race in the Illinois
Governors NBC News can now project that
Democratic incumbent JB pritzker
governor of Illinois has been re-elected
he has defeated his Republican
Challenger and in the Wisconsin
governor's race
this is previously too early to call it
is now too close to call between
Wisconsin Democratic incumbent Tony
Evers and his Republican Challenger Tim
Michaels that's with about 43 percent of
the vote in too close to call in the
Wisconsin Governor's race and on that
I'm back to go to our friend Simone
Sanders Townsend former Chief
spokesperson for vice president Kamala
Harris Simone I know that you've been
talking to sources on the ground in
Wisconsin we're obviously watching that
Senate race and also that that
Governor's race very closely what are
you hearing from your sources so
Democrats on the ground tell me about
the governor's race that they are
actually surprised that he's up this
early and it's a good sign but they
caution it there's still a long way to
go Wisconsin is a place where folks can
register to vote on Election Day
Democrats in the state spent a lot of
time and effort to turn out to increase
turnouts particularly among young first
Barnes versus Johnson numbers very
important in Milwaukee for example a
black voter turnout is up I believe they
said over 123 percent at this time in
the last midterm election young people
up 300 percent across the state they've
seen lots of great turnout over the long
lines on college campuses University of
Madison uh UW and Eau Claire in
Milwaukee so people are feeling
emboldened but they do caution it is
going to to be a long night now Mandela
Barnes campaign has said that they and
Mandela Barnes told me himself that he
is used to being the underdog here and
he's fine that people have maybe counted
him out but they are still quite
competitive and I think that we are
currently seeing that in the numbers
again it's still a long night Milwaukee
will take a long time to count because
different municipalities count
differently it's not a centralized count
and then Dane County again where Madison
is is still coming in but they feel good
and I have long since said Rachel that I
do think that it's not Pennsylvania that
is the most football seat for Democrats
it is actually Wisconsin
and Simone in terms of looking at those
two races simultaneously anything that
you're hearing out of the state anything
you know about these races and the way
they're being run what can you tell us
about Synergy between the Mandela Barnes
campaign and the Tony Evers campaign
because we're obviously getting reports
of votes from the same precincts in the
same part of the states but there's a
split with Evers coming in at a higher
percentage of the vote than let's review
some of these numbers ourselves because
they are getting it it's getting
actually to a critical point in a few of
these different places uh maybe we'll
just do a brief reset if you're just
joining us there are so many incredible
races going on right now not the least
of which is this race on the screen
Herschel Walker a man who can't speak
and can't think is tied with Raphael
Warnock
critically important in Georgia is that
if neither candidate gets 50 percent
there would be a runoff election the
reason neither has 50 is there is a
third candidate
who is you know one point something I
guess maybe
not quite two percent it's one point
something percent and then the the other
fraction must be write-ins or spoiled
who the hell knows uh there may be a
runoff
and it's possible that control of the
Senate could come down to that runoff if
you can believe that
so that is a absolutely critical
importance and we are watching that
we are uh we have been joined by a
number of different people already we
did a chat with Ian vosh the streamer
great conversation we had Brian Tyler
Cohen on I thought he was going to call
me back and we were going to then be
live on both streams but maybe not I
don't know what just happened but Brian
is
my Skype is open for whenever Brian
wants to come back
and we have been really kind of gearing
up for what is going to be one of the
most important two-year periods in
American politics that I will have ever
covered that I can tell you for sure
um folks support Progressive Independent
Media whoever you like okay is it Brian
is it for Ron Cuisines is it our great
friend Jesse dollimore thankfully
recovering well from his cancer surgery
it's you know Sam everybody you got you
guys know everybody okay
it costs nothing to subscribe to
everybody's channels look at these
numbers right here we have right now
17
000 people watching on YouTube almost
none of you are subscribed I know that
because you have no clue who I am
and that's fine
hit like hit subscribe this stuff is
free we've got to build the ecosystem
build the ecosystem and I know y'all can
do it
okay I know y'all can do it and by the
way we did launch a new coupon code
today
the code is 24 starts now
about a hundred people have used it so
far
go to joinpakman.com Alex Jones
literally hates what I do with
membership oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
that is a freaking Predator right there
he's not a knight at the round table
Pac-Man's a loser thank your lucky stars
every day you're not Dave Pacman part of
what Alex Jones hates
is this
it's this it's that I'm not selling
liquid silver
okay
hit that joinpakman.com let's make it
let's make it happen all right uh okay
other messages coming in you have to see
this Frank's speech is up oh hold on
let's see if I can get back on Frank's
speech we wanted to see what was up with
pillow oh here we go oh dear God we have
to see this let's see what's happening
on Frank's speech put your door at 6am
you mentioned Paul manafort I remember
reading in the paper they showed up hit
his house around 5 a.m and they threw
his wife out in the front lawn in her
nightgown wouldn't even let her get
dressed I mean so these are you know
this is I have friends who are at the
FBI some who are used to be at HRT and
so forth and the idea of allowing
yourself to be misused in that manner to
intimidate
an American citizen who is not violent
not charged with you know any crime that
would warrant that type of uh arrest
it's atrocious and it's really coming
people get I mean this is the
normalization of a police state and that
cannot be in this country I mean it
actually is pillow even on this
broadcast right now getting choked up
about it because people as I have almost
become kind of you know desensitized
desensitized to it and that's not right
that's not what this country is about
and there was the FBI whistleblowers
last name was friend I believe who was
brought the his story came out in the
New York Post talking about just these
types of things well listen let's it's
not exactly the most important thing
going on right now so so let's let's get
away from that but I do want to see
what's going on with pillow at some
point in time I don't wanna he probably
will lose his mind no matter what the
results are to be totally honest
uh but we'll we we will monitor that uh
okay all actually in the Iowa governor's
race NBC News can now project that the
Republican incumbent governor of Iowa
Kim Reynolds uh has defeated her
Democratic expectant Kim Reynolds will
be re-elected as Iowa's Republican
Governor you guys what Steve was just
saying that either I mean and Lawrence
talked about the history of midterms
incumbent president's party takes a and
I think above me is the word whooping I
think George Bush okay let's look at uh
some of the most important numbers that
are coming in not pillow if you guys
don't mind I'm going to close out a few
things uh I'm going to close Troth
Central uh oh we got to keep that open
for sure
I'm going to close vosh's stream
because I don't think we're going to
need it we already did this we already
did this I'm just cleaning up my tabs a
little bit because I just it's just
getting to be a little too much here uh
we're not doing the Crowder thing or the
Tucker thing right now we've got results
this I can close Okay this is like way
way cleaner right now
um whoa just a little pop there do you
see that all right let's go here we go
let's get the latest numbers from
Arizona
Democrats have made two gubernatorial
pickups so far in Arizona with 42
percent of the vote so here's what
happened in Arizona Arizona closed an
hour and a half ago but we didn't get
our first data until half an hour ago
about 40 percent dumped in right away
and now it's crawling
so 42 percent of the vote
Hobbes leading lunatic Cary Lake by 11.
okay
looking at the Arizona Senate with that
very same 42 percent of the vote this is
a critical race
Kelly is up 15 over freak Blake Masters
okay very very important other important
gubernatorial races Pennsylvania
is chugging along
it is now at 54 percent of the vote and
Josh Shapiro still leads by 14.
understand that in 2024
this race could decide who the next
president is
okay
in Pennsylvania the governor chooses the
Secretary of State
in 2024 the presidential election could
come down to Pennsylvania
if Doug mastriano a literal big lie
proponent January 6 attendee
picks
the Secretary of State
they're just going to try to steal those
electoral votes in Pennsylvania even if
the Democratic candidate wins this race
is of critical importance critical
importance good to see in Michigan that
Gretchen Whitmer is still up nine
only 25 percent of the vote
only 25 of the vote in
and then an important race in Minnesota
where the incumbent is well ahead and
then we also have Wisconsin where Evers
is up by six with 40 48 of the vote so
that's gubernatorial unfortunately uh I
believe it's it's over here it's over
here in Texas for Beto
what in terms of the House of
Representatives we are just kind of like
generally paying attention to what is
the shift Republicans are expected to
take control of the house and so far
they have picked up five seats that
being said
out of sheer
you know whatever
we are interested in Lauren bobert's
district with 71 of the vote in Lauren
bobert is losing by about four and a
half people saying check Illinois
uh do you mean Illinois Senate let's
look at that Illinois Senate
uh no you must mean something else
Illinois gubernatorial
no do you mean Illinois House
I don't know which one you mean yeah
it's complicated this is why it's tough
to look at house
okay let's back out of there the
important thing is Republicans have
picked up five seats so far other
important Senate races of course we are
really closely watching what's going on
here in Georgia Herschel Walker has now
taken a larger lead with 81 of the vote
Herschel Walker is now leading by about
half a point
that being said this would go to a
runoff
this would go to a runoff don't lose
hope quite yet it would go to a runoff
if these were the final results with
neither candidate getting to 50 percent
and then we get activated
in Georgia that's for damn sure do we
build a wall around Georgia one viewer
asks I don't know anything about walls
let me put it that way
uh okay let's see what other messages
are coming in from different people
eight more memberships dumping in
putting us at 2097.
thanks to everybody signing up on Twitch
as well very much appreciate you super
chats Herschel Walker in politics is
like Lindsay Lohan being a guidance
counselor Walker talks like the Family
Guy portrayal of Floyd Mayweather Jr wow
that's a lot
that's a lot search
David you are the best how do you think
Herschel Walker is tied I'm confused and
depressed well we have a very sick
country very very sick they're talking
about the race now point so I was
distracted because the point I was going
to make is you come in here and you
think okay Senator warnock's getting
blown out here right and he is and he is
but in close races to your point about
you know Brian Kemp popular conservative
governor who's doing okay in the
Democratic areas okay not horrific right
not horrific right but he's doing okay
and then you come out here where
Herschel Walker is getting 65 you say
well that do I why are we talking about
that right that's 30 points that's 31
points well we're talking about it
because of this uh because that's you
know 35 points right you just as you it
just says a little bit matters right
5971 votes for Stacy Abrams in this
County
sixty two hundred so it's but that's 300
votes for Raphael Warnock that Stacy
Abrams didn't get and it's 300 there and
then it's another couple hundred here is
what I'm saying so in the in the very
rural conservative areas of Georgia
warnock's getting blown out but by a
much not my by a smaller margin smaller
one 20 votes here 100 votes there matter
now imagine yeah listen I don't know
that that's really going to be enough at
the end of the day
uh for Warnock to get to 50 percent
will you know will it go to a runoff and
then you figure it out okay
but I just don't know that it's going to
be enough for Warnock to get to uh to
get to 50 and we're gonna watch that we
have to watch that one closely because
it is such a critically critically
important race
uh person has restarted the live stream
and is watching it from the beginning
well that's interesting for sure that's
very very interesting
um
let's see what else we have going on
here
um
yeah I don't know what's going on with
Brian
maybe I guess he does not want to do a
simultaneous thing on his stream right
now is that what's going on
let me see if I missed a message from
him
I did not
uh all right well
oh super chats are dumping in do you
think Walker even understands that if he
doesn't win get 50 percent
uh there's a runoff I I have it would be
totally plausible that Walker has no
idea how the runoff works yeah that's
that's perfectly plausible
Dem candidate should declare Victory
based on early voting results frankly we
did win I know listen they keep saying
that that Ohio is too early to call
great I mean keep it going for as long
as we can maintain hope
the Pennsylvania race has tightened up
quite a bit that's not so good
whatever happens tonight we know one
thing Kerry Lake will announce her win
folks it's over
it is over for mastriano thank goodness
projected winner against Republican
candidate Doug mastriano
this could be the 24 election you folks
we cannot possibly overstate the
importance of this result on a leader
even
um in the senate race but in this
governor's race NBC News has projected
the winner
Josh Shapiro versus Doug mastriano was
one of the starkest yeah well I mean I
will say the Wisconsin races now I want
you guys to remember when Trump claims
he's a hundred percent on endorsements
Trump endorsed mastriano and mastriano
lost it's not even close if different
different Visions for the state that
were more different than it's the
governor's race and the Secretary of
State's race because the governor
appoints the Secretary of State and what
was going to happen like I told Sylvania
uh with mastriano was one of those
issues that one of those possibilities
that made Joe Biden say democracy is on
the ballot indeed we could have lost
democracy Shapiro ran on extremism and
abortion and he tied it all together in
one of the most powerful speeches of the
midterm Saturday night in Philadelphia
um in that that big event with President
Biden and President Obama but he ran on
abortion he he also was the target of
anti-Semitic attacks on a daily basis
bestriano took money from gab I mean it
was sort of the center of the extremist
Maga movement running against a very
competent very message discipline very
very good candidate and Josh and by the
way Josh up here for two things one
thing is his margin if his margin stays
looking like that yes this is not a
state where you're necessarily going to
see people tickets there isn't you can
kind of see where there might be a you
know somebody who would vote for the
governor of Georgia the sitting governor
of Georgia but also vote for Warnock
it's hard to imagine a ticket splitting
voter in Pennsylvania the other thing is
that in Philadelphia one of the things
that campaigns that they were concerned
about was can they get the under-25 vote
out young voters are actually turning
out in higher numbers than Democrats
actually even expected them to Josh
apparel made a big play for younger
voters in Philadelphia for voters of
color in Philadelphia who were targeted
and and those issues abortion was a huge
issue for voters under 25 and so if he
maintains that kind of margin it might
be a big enough margin one other
interesting tool that I was just sent by
producer Pat is the New York Times
needles these are reacting at least to
the extent we believe it in real time to
what is happening with the vote count
and one interesting thing that you will
see here is that in the Senate races
uh where are they
yeah here we go in Pennsylvania
it is giving John fetterman a 66 chance
of winning in Arizona it's giving Mark
Kelly a 66 chance of winning
in Georgia however it has Herschel
Walker
at a 53 chance of winning which is not
great not great none of these needles
are zero none or 100 yeah I don't love
these needles it's not my favorite
visualization tool but it is something
too damn lucky says much love for
Michigan and cautious optimism for big
Gretch and prop three thank you for your
coverage appreciate it and thank you for
being here absolutely of critical
importance thanks to two more people by
the way who just grabbed memberships on
my website David if there isn't a red
wave in this economy isn't that a good
sign
uh if there isn't a red wave in this the
the economy is pretty good
do you know we may just I I may not
totally understand the context of your
question I most economic we're like full
employment record low unemployment
better than expected job creation better
than expected GDP less quarter
um
yeah I just I just don't know
necessarily
uh what you mean by that
um
okay let's see what's going on here so
the status of the counting in
Pennsylvania yeah so let's look at this
because officials there are doing this
Marathon counting that means that
they're not stopping until all the
ballots are counted so no one's you know
going home in the middle of the night
they're going to keep this up and we're
going to be seeing these results coming
in into some key counties here so John
you can kind of walk us through some of
this and give us a sense of what this is
going to mean for the night unfolding
ahead of us in Philadelphia we've been
told of course that these final results
there could take days we're now hearing
that officials are going to tell us
they'll do a press conference within the
hour to update on their status uh but of
course we don't know obviously this is
going to take some time with some of the
uh measures that they're taking there to
verify some of these ballots right well
Brianna just remind people because one
of the things that happened in
Philadelphia uh is that the Republicans
made a move and are demanding
Philadelphia election officials to take
steps that they're they're not demanding
of election officials in any other part
of the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania and
uh even the the Republican uh
commissioner was upset uh about what was
going on so that's right that's right
and in the end you had that Republican
official joined also by a democratic
official and they're going to go ahead
and proceed with that verification of
what they're seeing at the polls and
cross-referencing these ballots just to
make sure that they don't have anyone
challenging or that they should not be
able to actually challenge we'll see if
that actually means no one's no one does
challenge what they're doing right but
it just means it's going to add a lot of
time to it
um I want to head down to Berks County
so you see this here reading is
obviously in Berks County and so what
we're looking here at the mail in
ballots these are expected to be done
here in a few hours we're actually going
to see these in-person votes by midnight
uh so brew a little coffee but it's not
too much farther ahead of us right where
we're going to be getting some
information about what's going on there
let me jump in for one second she makes
the point that we have more ballots to
count again you're looking at margins
right so Joe Biden wins this I mean
Donald Trump wins this County by a
little bit more eight points right so
that's six points right there the
question is you know can John Federman
keep it that close it's just one County
but you're looking at margins all across
but as Bree notes we have some
outstanding votes to count sorry to
interrupt go
okay
so I was a little awkward right there
let's get back to Steve kornacki for a
moment memo kind of a public letter
telling the media and telling his
supporters how to think about the
results as they were coming in in
Pennsylvania and he was saying the way
that Pennsylvania is forced to count by
law is something that's going to make it
look like the Democrat is well behind
and so even though the Republicans may
look like their way ahead we have to
wait till it's all in everybody has to
be patient because the surge in
Democratic votes will come in late he
was describing that procedurally to
people to sort of set expectations for
what the vote count would be like was he
wrong in describing that that's how the
vote would come in or is he just doing
better than expected and so it doesn't
look like the Republicans ahead even
though that is the way the vote is being
counted no he was he was describing I I
heard a lot of this I felt you know a
lot of expectations for how the vote was
going to be reported in Pennsylvania and
other states was based on how it was
reported in the 2020 election we were
getting indications from election
officials that they had in their view
learned some lessons and come up with
new plans and so that's why right off
the bat tonight if folks were watching
they saw right off the bat within five
minutes of poll closings we got a
hundred something thousand mail votes
out of Allegheny County totally
different than 2020. then a few minutes
later we got something like 60 000 mail
votes out of Philadelphia again totally
different and a bunch of other counties
released huge batches of mail votes so
fetterman started the night it really
looks like the complete opposite of 2020
When Donald Trump built that big lead
based on the same day vote we've seen
fetterman build a big early lead in the
tally based on the Mayo vote being
released first in so many places and
then Oz playing catch-up as the
Republican counties and the same day
voters come in but as we're showing you
this really becomes a test of all right
fine 61 in Statewide let's look at the
counties where we get big vote and let's
measure them against 2020 and let's see
if one party's doing a little better or
a little worse than 2020 and so far the
trend that we're seeing seeing there's a
lot more still to come here but the
trend that we're seeing is that Oz isn't
really hitting those Trump 2020 numbers
he's come very close but he's not quite
hitting him and federman's doing a
little bit better than those Biden 2020
numbers and again Biden won the state by
80 000 votes in 2020 so I'm really eager
to see as these more votes come in
that's a very good sign that's a very
good sign for fetterman uh let's get
some of these updated numbers all over
the country and look at critical races
going east to west not a hugely
contested race nationally
but Kathy hokel remains about 25 points
ahead of Challenger Lee zeldon zeldin's
horrible 42 percent of the vote is in
there as they have been talking about in
Pennsylvania this is this is over
but this has been called for Josh
Shapiro this was one of the I believe
most important five races of the entire
election
and Josh Shapiro has won other networks
have already called it for Josh Shapiro
Doug mastriano very very scary lunatic
was at the January 6 riots uh thinks
Trump won in 2020 truly horrifying okay
so that is good news
um Michigan Michigan is one where there
is a trump endorsed Maga candidate named
Tudor Dixon right now she's down eight
but it's only 28 percent of the vote so
has not been called and we're continuing
to look at that in Wisconsin uh Evers
ahead of Michael's by uh about Five
Points more than half of the vote is in
that's important it is certainly not
over
in Georgia I did not expect it to be
particularly close and it's not Brian
Kemp about nine points ahead of Stacey
Abrams uh I think soon they're going to
be calling that surprised they haven't
already other very important Governors
races in case you don't know but I I'm
not surprised that these uh Ron DeSantis
it's already been called in Florida it's
a huge victory for DeSantis so far
um really crazy
I believe it oh it is it has been called
for Greg Abbott in Texas Beto has lost
Beto has lost
um and then of absolute huge importance
major major Bellwether Arizona
we are now up to 50 of the vote
Kerry lake is down by 14. This Is 50 of
the vote
carry Lake down by 14. super important
race almost like a Bellwether gut check
of insanity
super chats and different things coming
coming in thanks to call me ref for the
twitch Prime subscription really
appreciate that also thank you to
everybody who is signing up on my
website folks we have a new projection
here in Greg Abbott I just gave you that
one based off of uh other other data
um do not adjust your TV we really are
at 2113 new members it is an incredible
number
um super chat's coming in Kevin asks do
Georgia voters want to have men looking
at women looking at social media yes
that's a Herschel Walker quote I know it
makes no sense but it is
um seems like good overall turnout this
cycle watching fetterman Oz like a hawk
Shapiro and fetterman have similar
numbers not much split ticket voting
that's good news for fetterman I agree
uh
uh if bobert loses will she blame
critical race Theory yeah let's get an
updated look that is just like an ahaha
race
because Republicans will almost
certainly take the house but with 71 of
the vote bobert is losing by about four
I would love it if Lauren bobert lost
that would be really really great like
just fantastic it would be a fantastic
thing
we need to keep talking about corporate
Pro corporate profits driving inflation
not ignoring it well said I don't
disagree with you I think that that's
perfectly Fair
uh I do want to say thank you to
somebody who signed up with the name go
Stacey Abrams on the website
and his new member 2114.
uh a couple of voicemails are coming in
let's see what we got hey deep back John
again uh Brian Tyler Cohen is
busy right now I got you on one TV on my
55 inch and I have another TV that I'm
watching his live stream on nice but
yeah so you've got me on the bigger
screen that's important uh that'd be
cool if you guys hook up you're always
on my playlist every day so all right
have a good show don't be upset if he
doesn't get a hold of you later all
right thank you very very much hey there
David my name's Mike from northern
Minnesota I'm just actually in the midst
of uh
ran up some uh that's a lot because here
I'm watching it currently watching your
midterm election coverage Mike for all
that is Holy I hope you actually made
lotkas and not potato pancakes and that
this isn't a semantic confusion I really
hope you've got genuine latkes and not a
potato pancake so I'm not sure if then
even when this will get played I am
simply curious being in Minnesota I
don't know if you have paid any
attention to uh to the relatively maybe
minor player that is Minnesota we have
Kim Walls versus Scott Jensen doctor and
I put doctor in air quotes Scott Jensen
I I couldn't help but make the maybe
surface level connection between Scott
Jensen
with his family doctor status uh okay
this this one's going on a lot a long
long long time and I can read ahead the
transcript it's not really getting
anywhere so we're gonna bail on it for
now but we I really appreciate everybody
who's been calling in it's uh very much
appreciated also thanks to Jeff in
Boston for gifting five subscriptions
via twitch
um if we can't flip Texas or Florida
what's the odds in the future
well
we just have to wait and see how things
change I don't think we can make any
assessments today
it's looking good for fetterman looking
at the look at the Philadelphia
percentages I'm a little worried about
Oz lead leading in is it pronounced
reading or reading in Pennsylvania
because in Massachusetts it's reading
I'm sorry it's reading it's it's spelled
reading but it's pronounced reading
uh
uh not sure about that it's pronounced
reading okay very good
we are 13 minutes away from the next
tranche of results and it is of
absolutely
uh compelling nature to see what happens
at the top of the hour a lot of these
numbers are going to be filled in at the
top of the hour
we are only 13 minutes away and I hope
he will stay with us Jay says hi from
Erie Pennsylvania our county has been a
huge predictor for Pennsylvania in the
past few elections so far we are blue
let's hope the trend continues very
interesting perspective
not familiar with those uh that trend
um
let's go over to
actually let's stay here for now just
for a few minutes and for just resonance
status but then there's the overall
numbers too in terms of control of the
house is it conceivable that the
Republicans won't win control of the
house I mean is that even within the
realm of possibility yeah at this point
it is it's it's conceivable yeah that's
that's not a prediction or anything but
I'm telling you this is interesting I
have no sense of time here so I'm
looking it's 10 45 pm and well I mean
I'll take you through some of these New
York seats that are interesting but why
don't we start that on that big picture
question and take a look at the house
here and again we organize this sort of
by tier here starting with the front
line of Republican attack here these are
the most vulnerable Democratic seats on
paper just because these are the
Democratic seats that voted for Donald
Trump now what you see you see five
everyone that's read is a republican
flip and these are all districts we
basically teed up at the start of the
night the three in Florida along with
Georgia and Tennessee five all five of
these districts in redistricting were
redrawn basically in a way to elect
Republicans they all elected Republicans
they all represent flips we came into
the night knowing that there was almost
no circumstance where Democrats would
win a single one of these so those were
the five that were kind of baked in but
notice that nothing else has been
colored in on this first line of attack
from Republicans and in fact let's start
going through some of these Ohio's Ninth
District we've been following this story
tonight Marcy captor now up to about
three quarters of the vote in and again
Lucas County we got a lot of votes still
to come in Lucas County Democratic part
of that uh this is a big deal if
Majewski loses it would be glorious I
interviewed him he's a clown most of the
voters in and John Federman is running
ahead of the Buy number the congressman
from that area is Matt Cartwright
there's more vote to be counted but
Cartwright you see with more than half
the vote in you see the advantage he has
now again there's some descript there's
some disparities here in terms of you
know the male vote the share that this
accounts were but the Democrats are very
much in the game here the second
district of Maine this is you know
Donald Trump has won the Electoral from
this District in Maine they give out the
electoral votes by congressional
district Trump twice won this District
twice got an electoral vote out of it
Jared golden trying to defend the seat
he's running against Bruce poliquin who
he unseated in 2018. one thing to keep
in mind here is that Maine does instant
runoff voting so if gold and finishes
ahead of paloquin but short of 50 they
would go to an instant runoff Steve I'm
sorry to interrupt you we have an
important call and a very closely
watched race this is a senate race
projection in the great state of New
Hampshire Republicans really wanted to
pick off incumbent Democratic senator
Maggie Hassan failed in their efforts I
think they probably could have called
this way earlier but it's good to
finally see it called returning to the
United States Senate having beaten back
a challenge I appreciate the 100 Super
Chat love you David so excited for
Shapiro in rural PA worried for that one
for a while now with all the mastriano
signs disgusted with that guy since he
organized the Rudy hearing out here yeah
he's disgusting Democrats that they
might lose that seat at this hour the
Democrats hold 42 seats the Republicans
hold 43 15 seats remain undecided Steve
back to you yeah sorry hold on I've been
told that I should not go back to you
because I can interrupt myself again
totally expected in the Connecticut U.S
Senate race the Democratic incumbent
Richard Blumenthal will also be
returning to the United States Senate
again so we've just had calls in New
Hampshire and by the way that's another
Trump loss Trump endorsed Leora Levy she
lost so tomorrow whenever Trump's going
to tout his endorsement record he
endorsed Doug mastriano they flushed him
okay he endorsed Leora Levy they flushed
her 10 to 15 times
[Laughter]
if we're still here Chase Oliver down in
Georgia yeah he's okay we are just a few
minutes away
from
what are going to be the last major set
of results for the night as you can see
Herschel Walker is building a lead to
1.2 percent again
if nobody gets 50 there's a runoff
do we really want to take that chance
I don't know
it's not looking good
it's not looking good
uh but at least if nobody gets to 50
It's Not Over
it's not over okay folks I want to look
at the Pennsylvania numbers it's time to
look at Pennsylvania numbers let's look
at Pennsylvania Senate and see what is
going on with 65 percent reporting John
fetterman has now fallen below 50
percent
and his leading Oz by only 1.8 I don't
love that
that's not thrilling to me
so that we have to keep a very very
close eye on
in Arizona
with 51 reporting Mark Kelly is winning
by 19 points
this was a race that Republicans said
was winnable
It's Not Over
it's only 51 percent
but the fact that Kelly has a 19 point
lead over the freak show that is Blake
Masters maybe one of the worst people in
the world behind only Kerry Lake
I'd rather be up 19 than down 19.
can we put it that way
is that fair to say
similarly in Arizona
with 50 reporting Katie Hobbs is
14.1 percent ahead of Kerry Lake
Kerry lake is going to claim fraud if
she loses we know that
okay
you don't understand how important it
would be
to defeat Carrie Lake I have friends in
Arizona
who because of the Reproductive Rights
issue are thinking of leaving the state
if Carrie like wins
um
they're dealing with IVF and embryo
stuff and it's just the possibility of
carry like winning is truly horrible
[Music]
um
this is a really important one to be
following
and it it's still early
none of us are going crazy okay
but
that's that is really something
that is really something
uh the one that's not looking so good is
JD Vance uh ahead of Paul Ryan let's
listen to what Jen saki has to say that
people were predicting wouldn't be won
by them there was a narrative that
became increasingly untethered from the
data at a certain point and I even I got
up to walk my dog like 5 30 in the
morning made a mistake of checking
Twitter yeah oh go ahead
uh I'm gonna make a projection right now
we have a projection in that Ohio Senate
race where NBC News is currently it's
over that JD Vance key of formerly Yale
law Silicon Valley and hillbilly elegy
will be joining the U.S Senate defeating
Tim Ryan uh congressman from Youngstown
area who ran a
whatever involved was a great race but
those numbers there are 54-46 as we're
projecting this Michael Steele they look
like the gravity of the partisan makeup
of Ohio in the year 2022 pulling that
race to its fundamentals yeah in many
respects that's true so sadly you know
the polling there was no reason to
suspect there was Foul Play in that
polling that is the expected result and
I I don't think that's a big shock you
know we're really here holding out hope
that fetterman wins that Kerry Lake
loses that Mark Kelly wins it's still
too early to call but as you can see on
the screen with 51 in Blake Masters
losing by 19 which is really good to see
I mean that's absolutely horrible
horrible horrible
do I think it was a mistake for
fetterman to debate Oz Chelsea asks I
don't know
I don't know I think not debating would
have also raised a lot of questions and
created problems for him that's the
difficulty it's easy to say well it was
a mistake because it didn't go well
uh but I think not debating would would
also have caused a problem folks let me
do one more reset here we are three
minutes away from getting results in a
whole bunch of west coast states any
moment we are going to get those and a
lot of these numbers are going to be
filled in
we are going to be here
tomorrow
we will be here until every vote is
counted reporting to you on the podcast
and on YouTube and everywhere next
Tuesday we will be live with Donald
Trump's announcement from Mar-A-Lago
presumably that he's running for
president although we will see
I cannot more strongly implore you that
we can't allow Republicans to beat us
again
with the building of a media ecosystem
look at look at some of these numbers JD
Vance to some degree one because
Republicans built the local and
Independent Media ecosystem to a degree
to a degree next Tuesday is Trump sorry
for people who are confused not tomorrow
I'm sorry
a week from today
is Trump's big event at Mar-A-Lago okay
my requests to you today are simple
all of the shows that you like on
YouTube
please make sure
that you're subscribed it costs nothing
and it is the most important signal to
YouTube that they should be recommending
our content Beyond just to the people
that are already uh uh subscribe and are
on our site okay
these are live numbers
if you're watching right now
you can hit that subscribe button it
costs nothing and I really appreciate
everybody who has done so there's almost
20 000 people here most of them are not
subscribed we could dump in like 15 000
in an instant if you're watching on
Twitch make sure that you're following
us several hundred additional folks have
done that we always stream on Twitch and
of course if you're watching on Facebook
make sure to give us a like at the end
of the day shows like ours don't have
the corporate support
that folks like this do
okay
and the most powerful way you can
support the work that we do is to go to
joinpakman.com
2129 of you already have either on my
website or via twitch
join pacman.com we have a new coupon
code we launched it today
the coupon code is 24 starts now look at
this pricing folks look at this pricing
come on over
let's see if we can hit our goal of 2500
I believe this is the start
of one of the most consequential
two-year periods
in American politics certainly that I
have ever ever covered
in one and a half minutes we are going
to get some very important results very
important results and I look forward to
bringing those to you so far I have to
tell you the thing I'm taking the most
pleasure in are the Arizona numbers okay
primarily because she's such a
disgusting person
right now Kerry lake is losing by 13
points with 50 percent of the voting
there's no way it will end up being a 13
Point margin
but if Kerry Lake can be beaten off that
will be a great thing in addition Blake
Masters one of the worst people in the
world
is losing by 19 to Mark Kelly now we
haven't gotten updates here for some
time
the last update was 12 minutes ago here
uh and about 10 minutes ago here we're
watching both of those really important
races let's go now to the latest numbers
our
list which means we are expecting yet
more poll closings the poll closings
that are coming up in less than a minute
now are California and Idaho and Oregon
and Washington so we will bring you
characterizations of those races as soon
as those polls close I should also tell
you our political insiders were just
talking there a moment ago about uh the
projected winner in the Pennsylvania
Governor's race Doug mastriano was the
Republican Challenger the Democratic
attorney general Josh Shapiro is the
winner we're expecting a victory speech
from Josh Shapiro a few minutes after a
few moments after the top of the hour to
the extent that we are able we will try
to bring you some of that Josh Shapiro
victory speech in Pennsylvania and that
Pennsylvania Governor's race right after
these polls close beautiful at 11
o'clock on the East Coast we've got
polls closing in four states NBC News
election desk here we go project at this
hour these races as follows in the
California Senate race
the projected winner is democratic
incumbent Alex Padilla Alex padeo will
be returning to the United States Senate
in the Idaho Senate race the projected
winner is the incumbent Republican Mike
crapo in the Oregon Senate race it is
right now too early between incumbent
Democrat Ron Wyden and his Republican
Challenger Joe Ray Perkins in the
Washington Senate race we've got
incumbent Democrat Patty Murray facing a
republican Challenge from Tiffany Smiley
that race is also too early to call not
so good with some of the governor's
races the California governor's race
Newsom incumbent Democratic governor
Gavin Newsom obviously is projected to
have won that race he will be re-elected
as California governor and the Idaho
governor's race the incumbent Republican
is Brad little he is also projected as
the winner he will be projected to be
re-elected to that race
Oregon governor's race which is a very
interesting one it is too early to call
between Democrat Tina kotek and the
Republic Republican Christine Drazen now
again in that Oregon race that's worth
watching a third party candidate who may
be determinative in that fact but we
shall see in the Wisconsin Senate race
recapping some of our previous races
here but actually this one is a change
in characterization this one previously
had been too early to call yeah it is
now too close to call in Wisconsin
between incumbent Republican Ron Johnson
and his Democratic Challenger Mandela
Barnes
in the Georgia Senate race it is too
close to call between Herschel Walker
and Rafael Warnock 86 of the vote in in
the North Carolina Senate race with just
over 90 percent of the vote in it is too
close to call between Republican Ted
Budd and Democrat Sherry Beasley in the
Pennsylvania Senate race we've got about
71 percent of the vote in it is too
early to call between John fetterman the
Democrat and Republican Amendment Oz and
in the Arizona Senate race the Arizona
Senate race we've got 51 percent of the
vote in wow it is too early to call
between Democratic incumbent Mark Kelly
and Republican Challenger Blake Masters
At This Hour this is the control of the
United States Senate look at that
Republicans holding 45 seats the
Democrats holding 44 with that dwindling
number of undecided seats he's 11 Senate
seats still to be called there is one
house race that we want to point out
here
um
this is the Vermont at-large house race
and the reason that we are highlighting
this race in particular between Becca
ballant and Liam Madden Becca ballot the
Democrat and Liam Madden the Republican
is that in this race if Becca ballant
wins this she will be the first person
ever elected to Vermont while being
female we have never had a woman elected
either to the house or the Senate from
the great state of Vermont if Becca
ballant wins this race it's shocking she
will make history in that way in Vermont
do we also have a characterization on
the Vermont abortion race please
characterize just a moment we have a
call in a governor's race in Georgia
incumbent Republican Brian Kemp is
expected to be re-elected as Georgia
governor democrat Stacey Abrams was his
challenger but Brian Camp will return to
the governor's mansion in the great
state of Georgia and as I just mentioned
just a moment ago we're keeping an eye
on some of these abortion measures
around the country Vermont is one of
three states where voters were asked to
enshrine Reproductive Rights
reproductive Liberty in the State
Constitution that has won in Vermont the
yes vote is a vote not a surprise
abortion rights in the state
constitution in Vermont that measure has
won in Vermont Lots going on there
in terms of I mean at this point the
Fast and Furious nature of this is
starting to feel slightly overwhelming
although we're getting I think we're
getting a stronger sense of these
Contours well and you mentioned Josh
Shapiro will give a victory speech it'll
be interesting to hear if he mentions
the call from Doug mastriano he was one
of the election deniers and my
candidates who had said he may not
accept he said he would not accept the
results election so usually the first
thing that a Victor says is I got a nice
call from my opponent we'll be waiting
to see if he says I remember when the
candidates used to wait for them to call
right it would be rude of me to give my
victory speech if I haven't gotten my
call those were the days
all right ladies and gentlemen well the
voting will continue but as promised now
that we have reached the 11 pm hour in
the East this will conclude my coverage
I do have a show to film tomorrow
morning where we will analyze all of
this given Outlook and prepare for what
are going to be the next steps I am
cautiously optimistic about some of
these things we knew
that the most likely outcome was that
Democrats are going to lose the house
Steve kornacki told us it's not even
necessarily the case
we have to hope
that the numbers in Arizona stay
I think by tomorrow we will have a sense
of it the most important thing I can say
is Georgia Senate may be heading to a
runoff because Herschel Walker and
Rafael Warnock
don't have 50 percent but this Race
Kelly Masters this one could really
humiliate these clowns so let's hope the
numbers stay that way
two thousand one hundred and forty six
new website members and twitch
subscribers over our week of 2022
election coverage thank you
thank you I can't believe the numbers
that we got
and S press right on the money dumping
in 100 more subscriptions putting us at
22.46 folks 2024 starts right now
that's why the code is 24 starts now
thank you to all of you and we will see
you on the show tomorrow